draw
[Music]
if you really want it in the ring God
don't send the contract I'll knock his
contacts out you will feel mice trying
to take a Viper ain't no competition in
the ring of Cypher cause I'm spitting
phenomenal swinging fire talking pickled
peppers making paid a piper cause I
might go left discussion and deflate
your chest like a full production
new concussions in a dude a custom
attitude adjustments these are fighting
words better give me that respect that I
deserve for another knuckle sandwich
even got his one and only homie Kevin
you a phony homie now you owe me action
have em thinking Tony Tony rectum and
they all want to talk for attention but
the fame only lasts for an instant mama
got handsome bread for the pension imma
leave them red You Can Dance the
Redemption
thank you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome
presents no featured event of the
evening
as to
has to be presented boxing afternoon
[Music]
cause I'm spitting
Venom your fire talking pickled peppers
make them pay to Piper cause I might go
live like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a food production you'll
be talking like you want a new
concussions and a doodle custom attitude
adjustment these are fighting words
better give me that respect that I
deserve for another
Redemption
[Music]
foreign
put the ones in the chat if you can hear
your boy
the professional fan
am I coming in crystal clear
let me know what's going on out there
yeah yeah that's what I'm talking about
we got Lucius Augustus what's going on
Benjamin and Max what's good
kotm Productions was good Isaac what's
going on
boy we waited for this fight for a
minute
Craig was good yo we waited for this
fight for a minute right now I got uh
Devin Haney I'm warming up hey yo so um
I got good news to bring you guys
um
soon combat talk and uh I'm gonna be uh
starting my own channel so it's gonna be
called King's Corner and over there
you're going to catch Kos and you're
going to catch a combat talk and
um I'm gonna have a patreon going on
there so uh when you're a patreon member
uh I'm gonna give you an Avenue so you
can go check out the figure I'd say say
you be actually you know
doing the thing with me you understand
so what's good
hell yeah hell yeah big moves crazy big
moves all right so we got uh two drink
options two drink options right now
this is a weird margarita mix that I
made
um
pink lemonade margarita mix with a
little bit of um grapefruit I was just
gonna see how that's gonna taste and um
this right here is just uh
the pre uh C4 mixed with uh a little
Amaretto so that's that's whatever
that's just to stay up been up all day
been playing some tears of the Kingdom
whoo
it's ugly baby but I'm gonna tell you
that ugly baby got boobs on it baby
but we got what we got here
it's a tough last name is pronounce
Alma roll okay French for acting oh
that's what's up oh okay that's what's
up Salute King remember for two months
now a long time listening to sipping on
the famous oh pencil oh that's what's up
whole 60s 30 of that line scotch and
hunting lemon tuna drink that's what's
going on brothers that's right I'll have
a little something to sip on no because
we home and we relax and we grown we get
to do that you know as we being grown yo
all right so I know everybody got a
chance to see the weigh-in yesterday
with uh Devin Haney and lomachenko
lomachenko uh coming in at 135 and Devin
Haney coming in at uh 134.9
um I didn't expect that uh honestly you
know I thought uh uh lomachenka will
come in lighter but you know Devin Haney
coming in a little bit uh Killian was
good coming in a little bit
slightly heavier that that's that's
that's kind of wild and then we saw the
shove now if anybody didn't see it
there's a chub where uh Devin Haney
shoves lomachenko at the at the weigh-in
and I mean there's not nothing big you
know we've we've seen it we've seen
Canelo shove uh Kayla plant we've seen
Floyd shove and choke Ortiz
um all types of stuff we've seen these
things happen you know
um is it any indication of something
um
is a psychological advantage I don't
think Devin Haney should have did it to
be honest with you because I think
lumachenko starts slow I don't know if
lomachenko starts a little bit fast I
don't know if lomachenko uh feels that
you know he wants to show him a little
something maybe Devin Haney thinks that
works in his favor
I don't know me personally
um I'm Gonna Keep a piece all the way
through until we get to the actual
situation and then boom you know then
you're gonna catch this work that's
that's my opinion of it that's how I
would handle it let me see that's right
hold the line
Devin has no power loma's response sub
King
not a tuna Ginger been sipping though
that's what's up he said it cures
everything yo um
I honestly believe that uh
Loma is the the better fight of the two
right and and Loma being the better
fight of the two I think Loma brings
something to the table that Devin hasn't
seen before
and I believe that you know that you
know Devin believes that uh Loma doesn't
have it anymore
I'm sorry I'm not in that camp to
believe that I believe sometimes you
know Fighters
um
get get up for fights right and if he if
he gets up for a certain fight then fine
if he doesn't get up for a certain fight
then you know um it's whatever he wasn't
in Jeopardy of losing his last fight
because he was fighting his sparring
partner I just feel honestly that you
know everybody looked at that fight and
and tried to judge lomachenko and
thinking that he's on a decline and
everybody think that when he fought tear
FEMA Lopez that he was on the decline I
don't believe so I believe Timo Tio Fimo
was fading at the end of that fight and
Loma misjudged uh how much time he had
left to fight him so
um I think at some point in time we're
going to see the real lomachenko stamp
up I I think this fight is everything
that lomachenko wants he's going to give
Devin Haney everything that he asked for
a pulse and I believe that this this is
going to be a crazy fight so let me see
what we got here
who got whoo right now if you got
lomachenko put one in the chat if you
got Devin Haney put two in the chat you
know um
and I I think uh distance plays a huge
part in this fight because Devin likes
to fight at Range four and and
okay well for people that don't like uh
they don't know
um
fighting games Devin Haney likes to
fight at long distance to medium range
and lomachenko likes to fight from
medium to zero range
all right let me go let me see uh
heated heavy 505 member for 35 months
that's what's up one day we may call a
fight together why not I gotta up my
fight game though keep doing your thing
blessings brother
um it definitely is going to be a call
in so you see the calling joint is there
that's been in the works for a minute
um me personally what I needed was a
producer to get that done um the cash
app really works that's like my real
cash app that's not even a joke oh I
know it sounds funny fund me bank but um
it's a Jamaican thing
um and I'm West Indie I'm not Jamaican
but um it was it was it was a play on
the joke that I have with a friend of
mine
um yeah y'all be able to call in you're
gonna be able to call in on the phone
we'll be able to talk fights you'll be
able to see certain things
the patreon is going to be lit my plans
for the patreon I'm sitting down with
some people talking about it my plans
for the patreon is going to be lit uh
it's it's gonna be a great place for
y'all to come talk fights watch fights
and and
go with fights all right so we got one
Loma Loma Loma Loma Loma Isaac too
um what else we have here
two hold the line if Loma can't get in
one Hold the Line this message is held
hold on I got you I got you and yeah
that's right there we go yeah yeah it's
it's gonna be something dope that's what
that's what I'm looking for I'm looking
for something different something that
other people ain't offering and a lot of
times people come inside the space but
don't bring anything different right and
if you if you're going to get into the
space you got to bring something
different you can't bring the same thing
that everybody breaks so I'm trying to
bring something different when I call
fights I call fight different from other
dudes dudes sit there and give you
reactions to shots that they see they
don't tell you exactly how the fight is
going
um I'm not going to tell you exactly how
the fight is going and um you know if I
gotta watch the fight over later again
you know as a you know relax and stuff
like that then I'll do so but
me personally I definitely watch the
fights to have a good time and you know
y'all dudes tuning in with me is
everything
um right now we got UFC up
and I'm gonna be calling UFC so it's
gonna be fight night every weekend
and I'm gonna try my best to call UFC
and you know more than likely I'm gonna
mess up a lot on UFC but um
because right now
we have uh who is these two
there is no way is these two old older
Fighters and I've seen these two
fighters fight before
and that's the only thing that's in
boxing in boxing to give you the names
down at the bottom and you'll see they
don't you'd be like you better know who
he's watching
let me see Loma got got plus money on
the books this this is true uh King I
see you on Twitter still holding the
line but your prediction for tonight my
prediction for tonight
um after seeing a weigh-in if I'm
betting money I'm betting money on Loma
um my heart goes with Devin Haney you
know he's a younger fighter he's the
future of boxing
but something tells me Loma is going to
cut that distance he's going to slip
that jab he's going to Parry that jab
and something tells me that he throws
heavier shots than Devin Haney
um I believe Loma could take a better
punch than Devin Haney so I believe
that's going to be a war of attrition I
I honestly believe from while round one
to round 12 it's going to be all about
who can take the best shot and who can
slip more and who can actually work
and I think Loma Loma what his
experience is going to show Devin Haney
certain things that he's never seen
before in the ring
dip down what's good what's the king
happy to make it to another combat talk
with the man that's right the myth the
franchise King let's go let's go let's
get those likes up guys and girls what's
going on Benjamin what's good people's
SP we're in for good treat tonight hole
Yeah Loma has to neutralize the jab
that's the longest biggest problem in
this fight
and I think he's going to neutralize the
jab by
um okay so Loma Southpaw right so when
he's coming in he's gonna block Perry
and the jab is going to come in and he's
going to block Perry right so it it's
it's he's gonna come in he's going to
punch it he's gonna like tap it up and
it's gonna he's going to slip under it
so it's like tap up and then he's moving
you know Loma has Superior feet
and his feet closes distance and if you
see me doing this with my head is
because that's exactly how he's going to
be moving he's going to be moving in and
out and he's going to be giving a lot of
faith he's going to be putting so much
pressure on Devin Haney Devin Haney has
to be able to deal with that pressure so
that pressure that Loma is going to be
doing is going to be going in and out
he's going to be moving side to side and
that's exactly what lomachenko did to
Gary Russell Jr even though I thought
Gary wrestler Jr going into that fight
was going to beat lomachenko
he showed Gary Russell
they weren't in the same class it wasn't
in the same hemisphere I thought that
was Gary Russell's worst beating to me
because Gary Russell had opportunity to
win uh King's gonna be spitting tonight
facts though
I feel the same way and I feel Devin
Devin I want Devin to win but lone is
slightly better fight in my eyes king
holds the line like a statue immovable
that's what's up as someone who has
never watched the fight before how did
you learn
how do you learn what is important
um the most important thing is feet in
boxing
right
because feet is going to get you to
where you need to be and then the second
most important thing is hands
right so your feet and your hands must
move in unison any good box any box of
worth is salt and I'm talking about a
box I'm gonna talk about a fighter or
umbrella I'm talking about a boxer any
box of worth is salt his hand and his
feet are inseparable when I move my
hands and my feet
they're one like my left foot and my
left hand is one my right hand and my
right foot is one and how they move is
how I move right and
once you train that once you teach that
once uh the the boxer understands that
then you can start worrying about power
distance and and and all types of
intricacies like combinations and stuff
like that but the beginning the most
important thing is your foundation is
your feet your legs how your body moves
right because
your training is going to be centered
around your lower center of gravity
those are the things that's not striking
anybody that your feet is going to get
you into Striking Distance and your feet
and your hands must know at all times
once I close the distance what I'm gonna
do right so if you jump jump forward
with your uh your your front foot your
lead foot your jab is double jabbing in
so your foot Taps twice your jab is
tapping twice and that's how you control
a fight if it you know sometimes they
tell you that you know some dudes got
Happy Feet and stuff like that look at
their hands moving then their hands is
moving just as much as their feet
Muhammad Ali hands and feet move
together uh sugary Robinson hands and
feet move together Oscar De La Hoya was
a little flat-footed so that's why his
jab was stuck the the more flat footage
you are the more your hands stay at Bay
right and if you feel that you have to
stay flat-footed to to punch you're not
going to be as successful as a fighter
that can move and punch at the same time
all right let me see active facts do you
have a prize that is uh a prize statue
back there behind you one that's not
going anywhere for any dollar amount
this one right over here my Doctor Doom
uh he's like uh but five thousand
dollars
I love that Doctor Doom but I also love
that doctor doing and my Hawks
um I don't I don't think my Hawks
um I love my Hawks like my Queen studio
hulk on throne
beautiful statue oh my God the level of
details on that statue is insane it's
sickening how much detail is in that
statue that statue is one of my best
statues but then my red Hulk I I'm I'm
in love with my statues like my Dolph
Mall statues is in impeccable
um so if I had to like somebody asked me
if I was running in here and I could
only run out with one Statue
it will probably be my transformation
Hulk
um my Hulk transformation statue where I
have Bruce band and he's in the front of
him and then Hulk is changing and he's
all that
um because that statue reminds me of
um me watching Bill Bixby as a as a kid
growing up and Hulk on TV so that that
probably be the statue that I'll run and
Save
oh okay I'm frequently defined to do
podcast listen I've always heard great
things from this channel especially from
the gold Cog this is a badass that you
guys are doing a live stream for this
fight thank you Logan
um I'll definitely be here more often I
appreciate it I agree with that feat
game get you to the foundation King King
what up bro what up Simon Mackenzie
what's good thanks brother thank you
hold the line 100 Haney's excellent back
foot fighting alone was a great front
foot fighter that's what the thing is
about trust me SP King can't have a
statue of limitations
that's what's up yo that that was a
great breakdown uh SP
Devin Haney fights great on his back
foot lomachenko fights fantastic on his
front foot
we're going to see if they can reverse
roles tonight
the person that can actually uh do so
will probably be victorious in this
fight the person that can actually uh do
what's outside of their comfort zone and
become more than what they they they
they they they are
to be uh exactly who they need to be to
win because isn't that about winning
right the person who becomes the most or
becomes uh who who they aren't is is
going to be victorious this is what I
believe
right now
um
we have uh
let me see checking
all
okay
oh my God
that was one hell of a knockout right
there UFC right now I put up some uh the
first fights that was uh going up on um
the boxing that was crazy
I what I would do if I'm doing UFC
um
for novices like myself
the name in the corner
down at the bottom to let you know who's
who and what corner and so you can you
know have a position on it but right
here right now okay so we have uh Jaquan
Buckley uh 16 and six uh 12 wins by
knockout Jerome Buckley I guess he just
won right now and then interview him at
the end of the fight uh Jaron he looks
like he he he fights right and the
person is interviewing them fantastic
fantastic y'all got to check this out
that's pretty good
UFC ESPN live watching it right now
King uh let me see audio I see you King
what's going on Dragon heart oh you talk
about the SMS yeah yeah you know I'm a
50 Cent supporter New York all day man
come on man that's what you got to do so
you're saying whoever is more
comfortable in their uncomfortable Zone
wins the fight yes
um
because it takes it takes an individual
to to be uncomfortable I mean
comfortable in those uncomfortable
moments because those uncomfortable
moments will show up in this fight right
in this fight Loma will be backed up
can he have success going backwards
because you know he when he goes back
which is going to go side to side right
you know Loma has a good feet you know
side to side he's going to Dart in but
can't he has success going backwards
because Devin Haney have success coming
forward
you know um when he's not the counter
puncher when he when he's in range zero
is he going to hold because whatever
Haney does as soon as you close distance
he holds he grabs he makes sure that oh
no no no no no please no no and that's
what it looks like and then when he was
fighting Jorge Linares Jorge Linares
caught him with that sneaky right hand
Wobble the brakes off of him
if that was Loma if that was a tank if
that was the other individuals that
actually can close the show
would he still be there but you know we
can play the F game all day that's not
who he was fighting he is fighting Jorge
Linares for a reason and that's why he
was able to get that victory
you ever see the movie Warrior King damn
King good fight movie yeah torn uh yeah
Tom Hardy is bigger than when he plays
Bane yeah that's yeah he did I saw that
oh yeah I had those Wireless joints
fired all day always support 50 that's
my guy yep sure did lights out facts
facts
oh that's Rashad
wow I did not know that was Rashad on um
on the panel right now I did not know
Rashad had dreads come on man this these
dudes right now we have to stop as men
I'm I'm on the movement I'm not with the
fake hair I'm not with the you know
putting on the man wigs I see you guys
Instagram is lit you guys be having
could you imagine me right now bald
headed in tomorrow y'all see me with
dreads come on man that's that's not
good that's not cool we men not man
should not do that
all right man should not put Pawn wig
Pawn them head no man no I say no man
I'm not I'm not voting for that Rashad
take that off your head man last time I
saw you was going bald in the back of
your head there come on how you gonna
have a whole ponytail
that's wild disgusting cut that out man
wigs crazy yeah come on son
Rock what nature gave you that's right
these dudes out here cheating
and I know Rashad has gray hairs now I'm
not saying yo listen remember I was
doing it just for men for a minute
I was holding the just for Man game down
and I told dudes when I reached a
certain age that Just For Men had to
stop
just for those other men I'm gonna keep
this you know gray bed all day
these dudes here but I know you're on TV
man but you know the wig don't do it I
can see where his hair is ah come on man
that is so oh way that's bad bad luck
for old boy
I'm getting my dress back when I when I
had him before the lady was telling me
do you want to put a weave on the yeah
make it longer they didn't know what the
[__] get away from me thank you yo thank
you thank you rock them up you rock your
soul Pepper too that's what's up my wife
was like she's she on it so I'm like I'm
gonna keep that I'm not worried about it
as long as my wife love it I don't care
if if she was making me feel bad about
it like baby you need to dye your joint
you're looking kind of weird
then I'll probably be like oh no I'm in
trouble but nah man now I'm I'm cool
with it I'm just going back and forth
checking making sure everything is fine
because right now is the intermission
the prelims was over
so what they're doing is they're doing
intermission so I'm going back and forth
watching UFC
the UFC is fighting ESPN live fights is
fighting
um UFC these I know these two old dudes
um they're old heavyweights and it sucks
that they don't put their name down at
the bottom but they're battered they're
bloody their bruise
yo that is gonna be so much fun talking
about these dudes
face is messed up I can't wait to be
able to show you the joints too we're
going to be working on that too
yo what's going on Monty Brooks
and biggest was good
get assaulted and peppery would come
with his facts you
this fight is getting ready to jump off
soon what time it be
check the time
oh yeah 10 21 we're early we're early yo
he slammed this dude so hard on his back
oh my God he just picked him up and
slammed them they both tired they're
both old they're both tired
good to see you too
pause on the name
ah I lost podcast salute brother what's
good hold the hairline
now Rashad not trying to do that man
Rashad trying to keep a ponytail upon
his head
I I can't see it I can't even see going
sitting down in a Bobby's chair
and like all right yo um put my tracks
in
could y'all imagine y'all pull up
tomorrow and I'm not doing a skit I'm
not doing a comedy I'm like they're not
doing Jamaican gym or something like
that and I actually put up with an app
that's highly disgusting boy
watching the NBA game would try to
Bootleg the box and match that that's
what's up King did you watch uh Katie
tiller versus Cameron great fight yeah
that fight was pretty good earlier that
fight was pretty good early I was going
in and out because I was playing tears
of the Kingdom so I was just like
looking I was just checking time yo when
you trying to manage time in between
time you know I made sure everybody ate
everybody good we got we got food it's
Saturday everybody ate
let me get over here let me go do this I
got one screen going on there I got this
screen going on there I'm making sure
that the live stream is gonna be good
checking that out putting that stuff up
checking the vocals doing everything
I said let me get in a couple of uh
shrines let me do some shrines and um
yeah I was watching the fight from the
side eye though it wasn't the main fight
so excuse me
Hold the Line King what's going on put
my trash in yo I got something special
for you guys tomorrow if you're tuning
in to IOP tomorrow I got something
special for you guys tomorrow if y'all
look at my Twitter tonight like after
tonight right after
the fight
I'm going to do something on my Twitter
timeline
that's going to give you an indication
about tomorrow on IOP and something's
going to be live and
uh you know whether you rock with me you
don't and if you hear I guess you rock
with me right
um it's going to be something that you
guys would really appreciate
um
it's it's going to be really nice and
and I hope you guys really like it
yeah I'll be there bright and early yeah
um something out uh we work really hard
on
um the support from the whole team
basically the whole community
uh you guys are incredible it's
something like
um
something something is humbling it's
absolutely humbling but what I'm what
I'm what I'm putting out y'all y'all
should definitely appreciate it oh and
shout out to math anybody that saw that
math video math hook uh hit me up in the
background was like yo you inspired me I
wanted to do this thing and and shout
out to math math uh put a whole video a
rap video up and with me and Satya and
you know it was it was funny it was dope
it was creative and that's exactly what
I want to do I want everybody to be
inspired have some type of creation uh
get out there and do something that's uh
different do something that you've never
done to become something that you've
never been that's what I want
how's the family doing oh everybody's
great we're solved showing up for combat
talk soon soon so if you pull up the
dreads and afro we burning
yes yes yes that's true my video was
great definitely I saw it and lost it
was hilarious mad is yeah math is wow
hilarious that is my guy man I'm totally
respect him love everything he does over
there and fun speculation
um and I think more people should do
more stuff outside of the box more stuff
than that you don't do like you know
show show people who you are like who
who's the fun you like who's the person
that you you like you know and I'm
pretty sure everybody else will like it
too you know because we talk offline and
instead of you know dudes being buttoned
up you know like today's news uh in Xbox
world uh uh no I don't care for that you
can get that on you know channel five or
whatever you know Microsoft has brought
stocks and uh Hey because they're trying
to push forth you know they ain't gonna
get hold the line they ain't gonna get
that you know what I'm saying so you you
got to give them something different you
got to give them something something
different man be something different
quick thoughts on NBA playoffs my heat
might end up making it to the finals
math is funny but definitely need a
Ghost Rider oh God he needs a Ghost
Rider I definitely was going to hook it
up with my man you know I definitely
hook it up with Dallas you know Dallas
doo do bars and stuff you know
um
NBA finals
my next gone I don't care I'm Gonna Keep
it a buck with you my next gone I don't
care
um
I see dudes repping LeBron I like LeBron
um repping the Lakers
if the Lakers make it then the Lakers
make it so what you know
I'm such a New York homer I'm a Jets fan
we got Aaron Rodgers this year
um I'm gonna be probably watching
football
like I've never watched football in in
in the last couple of years you know um
I think Aaron gives us a shot to do
something spectacular you know I I
thought Jalen Brunson did something uh
with the Knicks that and Tom Thibodeau
did something that was um
special you know anybody calling for Tom
thibodaux's job is is mental uh so
all I need is a couple of pieces one or
two pieces uh get those pieces in there
and while Jalen is still young and you
know Tom Thibodeau still has that fire
inside I don't think that fire ever
leaves a real Coach and maybe we can
make a deeper run into the playoffs you
know
um I'll take a Klay Thompson even though
he's diminished as he is because them
dudes is talking about shopping Clay
Thompson bro and um I take a Clay
Thompson you know with the Knicks um
he's a good shooter regardless to what
and all we need is somebody that could
put buckets in you know somebody at the
moment ain't too big for them that's
exactly what we looking for that's what
I'm looking for
let me see oh he's going on man they're
making me some cash that's what's up
that's right that's why I created my own
brand for the international Properties
LLC the game behind the game is Sean I'm
always good company that's right brother
I was laughing for real a little Denver
winning though at LLC tax write-offs and
awful old jokes hell yeah
it's still judged though so I'll be
hiring on the dot on the dial caution
just kidding I'm only winning by second
of the third quarter yeah yeah I feel
you I'll be on Aaron I'll be on I'll be
airing on the side of course yeah I I
feel you there's the Jets and you know
we we go by same old Jets
right now I'm waiting for the
intermission to start and you know the
pay-per-view to actually uh kick in
um
I yo my Jets has been kicked so so so
much that
um I
I go into stuff with trepidation you
know what I'm saying I I'm not gonna sit
here and tell you I'm not going to be
fearful for my Jets but at the same time
I'm hopeful man I I do want to see a
championship within my lifetime you know
I was there for Joe Namath winning no
ring even though Joe did it with a with
a with a a mink Kirk a fur coat now he
didn't have a mink was it a fur I think
it was a fur and you know you know the
king love is fair coach So Young Fly and
flashy dude I'm down with that young
flying flashy you you you do you doing
it yeah he brought that braggadocious
New York style to it I'm gonna win a
championship hell yeah I want to see
that in my lifetime I thought Keyshawn
Johnson was going to do it I thought
Vinnie tests the Verdi and Keyshawn was
going to do I thought that was going to
get done and um Vinnie towards Achilles
and there goes that but right now
they're talking to Devin Haney Devin
Haney's getting his hands wrapped he
looks calm uh so is lomachenko
lomachenko's getting his hand wrapped
they look calm uh I think the first
fight we have Oscar Valdez uh fighting
somebody and um that's gonna be a good
fight so uh we once we get past the ask
about this fight then we can get to the
Loma lomachenko um Devin Haiti fight
that's that's going to be an indication
of
uh are we going to get Shakur Stevenson
versus uh somebody
um because right now they talk about
really Ramil versus Ryan Garcia I think
Ryan Garcia knocks rolly out cold I give
that a whole four rounds no more than
four rounds Ryan Garcia knocks uh
rolling Romero out Cold and takes that
belt that he got from barbaros because
um me personally I I don't think uh
Rowley was even supposed to win that
fight I mean he was going to lose the
fight I'm a puny guy all jokes aside I'm
a die hard charger fan so trust me I Got
It Bad too yeah but your charges was
good though your charges was good a
minute ago man yeah listen man you you
got to go pretty long and pretty far for
when uh the Jets was good you know Mark
Sanchez
oh no hold on
oh no
got four years ago
on top of the world yes we have the
Oscar Valdez Adam Lopez fight coming up
next and it is Haney and Lola machenko
let's go to the races
ladies and gentlemen may I have your
attention oh no
Jim Brown was a giant on the field and
off I'm gonna take some online
he was an activist oh my God man Jesus
let me see what we got here
trust me I Got It Bad too or Ryan knocks
rolly out early retirement yeah jazz fan
is different respect rest in peace Jim
Brown they doing Jim Brown right now
that Paul's they talking about Jim Brown
right now I like the Jets when Mark
Sanchez was there me too but only
because Mark Sanchez
fit the the the face of what you want
your quarterback to look like I mean
let's keep it a buck everybody wants to
face today franchise it looks like
something that they could put on a
couple of GQ or whatever the hell and
still throw football
um
I thought Zach Wilson was going to be it
you know and obviously to just decided
yo you know what we're gonna we're gonna
turn around from this we're gonna get
past this
um and and that's that so
rest in peace
let me see
yeah Sanchez suggest was OG you good
yeah um now I'm texting uh my wife she
did something that she wasn't supposed
to do you know as far as the dog goes
uh I already gave the dog its medicine
so
uh
whether you're Devin Haney to rain or
Vasily lomachenko to snag the duck
oh boy
the butt fumble that yo yo
that's when I knew we were cursed
do you know what it's like
to have your quarterback run into the
rear of the tight end and the fumble the
ball and lose the game
my heart fell
and I was still riding with him yo yo
you can't front you can't front you know
um
the coach was dope at that time
he willed us to win and the fact that
they was behind Mark Sanchez
um
I think that's that's what hyped us up
and then you know our defense was crazy
can't wait you know what I'm saying like
you can't wait you know that that that
Joy had me hyped and we went out there
and beat Tom Brady on the field
boys was thirsty to get that dude oh man
pause yo
I I I knew
I've I've
you know we don't like New England let
me keep it a crazy Buck like we don't
like New England we don't we don't like
New England we don't like what Belichick
did when Belichick had the opportunity
he had a job and Belichick walked off
the job you know after the Bill Parcells
jump off and Belichick just dipped out
on us and went over there and proceeded
to beat the brakes off us with some
quarterback that he find in the bushes
that becomes the greatest quarterback to
ever walk there
I don't care if you like Joe Montana I
don't care who your quarterback is Tom
Brady is the greatest quarterback who
ever threw that ball until somebody can
do what he did
he is Captain America and that's it and
that's all and I'm I'm come it's coming
from a dude who can't stand the Patriots
cannot stand them
gotta respect them
you see that's the difference a lot of
dudes don't understand that I can't
stand current PlayStation
can't stand them but I respect them
you gotta respect them somebody's doing
consistent greatness you gotta respect
and so ain't no need to talk down on Old
Boys none of that don't right now and
I'm Tom Brady step on the field respect
to go I remember the time laying her
back told Wifey right she thought the
game was over
Patriots was down she thought the game
was over I said you're bugging I said
watch she fell asleep I said watch when
I wake you up I woke up Tom Brady was up
by seven told you
wait we're like uh uh 20 seconds to go
told you Captain America don't do that
don't ever bet against that dude that
dude crazy
let me see Rivers Island hell yeah Rivas
Island was good we was living good
hate that franchise cost me
King what's your thoughts on Ryan Garcia
and going with Derrick James and his new
trainer
um
the fact that Ryan Garcia understood
that going with Derek James or going
with a a trainer that can show you that
he can consistently produce fighters of
the generation
Jamel Charlo
and and Earl Spence is arguably two of
the best lighter weight Fighters period
right and Derrick James
guided them to where they are to to the
point that Errol Spence if bud can stop
ducking Errol Spence will be undefeated
I mean um or will be Undisputed Jamel
Charlo is already
um Undisputed
so and he also has uh Anthony Joshua in
his Camp so the foreign Garcia to go
there see the problem with Ryan Garcia
is the way he throws his punches he
throws his punches like he has no
official training right so that's that
tells me that you don't have any
repetition you don't have no structure
he needs structure that's it when he is
fighting tank and I told people when he
was training he was training for
somebody who was up here he wasn't
training for somebody it was down here
and you punch and you train you train
for somebody that's where you're going
to be punching at you do not train for
somebody up here you don't be throwing
Jabs in right hands and wide hooks up
here that's why all those punches went
over Tank's head tank slipped majority
of those punches with not a problem
right so and that's a problem
and then he has an injury
so me personally I would have had we
would have to postpone the fight at
least two weeks I don't care I don't
give a damn something let me heal but I
don't think Ryan would have won that
fight anyway I had tank beating him
anyway I had tank knocking him out
anyway
the problem is Ryan
is his chin he doesn't know how to duck
um jab and keep his shoulder there
um he needs to learn defense
not offense and I think Derrick James is
going to teach him how to control
distance and try and teach him how to
move his feet because Ryan's legs don't
look good when he's moving
he doesn't look good going backwards he
doesn't look good going lateral he looks
good going forward he looks good when
he's standing still so Ryan Garcia with
Derrick James is a perfect fit for me
let me see uh he's a bad man Valdez
fight is about to start that's right SP
we see him right now you are hype when
Brett Favre joined Joe
um Brett Favre I knew Brett Favre threw
more into interceptions than he threw
touchdowns and
all right and when you give uh old
veteran that ability to run the
franchise is never going to go well I I
just thought you know I hope that Brett
Favre would have brought something but
Brett Favre was just coming for a check
and seeing what type of caliber the
individuals is after all the Scandal
allegedly of what he's done in the high
schools taking those uh those low
franchise I mean those those little
economic conditions and doing what he
did with that stuff we're not even gonna
go into that but that that's the caliber
individual and I kind of felt that I saw
that
um also the stuff that was going on with
a lot of the female people that was
involved there you know you hear it
comes out and stuff
um I kind of felt that I kind of saw
that because remember we get a chance to
go up there and watch them practice so
I've I've gone up there and I watched
these guys practice and you could see uh
people when they stop and they sign
autographs and they don't have to they
talk to the kids when they don't have to
they do things
um
out of out of the love and and I mean I
think that generally comes from a
general good person right or person that
doesn't feel that they're up there so I
just never got that from Brett Favre so
I didn't have those expectations for
greatness from that that individual at
all
knockout showing support for the Harlem
New York City how do you how did you get
so much knowledge about boxing what up
phase I used to box
it's the box I um
I met Muhammad Ali when I was supposed
to go to
um
Shabazz boxing was gonna Shabazz was
gonna sponsor me that was on um 116th
Street
um it's it's a Muslim it's a mosque and
they have uh barber shops and stuff like
that and I was going to go to all
lenards and Terry Norris uh boxing camp
in Texas and I was going to I was going
to be that dude because I was literally
a dude I used to hang around panel
Whitakers God bless uh sleeping peace uh
king
um Iran Buckley was uh one of my best
friends who used to hang around with
Iran Buckley
um
Mitch Green one of my best friends Fort
Mike Tyson has to do Mike Tyson bust
upside his head out in front of a Dapper
dance
uh a lot of times you know um I'm in
around and always around uh boxing
circles Superman Aaron Davis uh one good
friend of mine he he saw me later on and
he was like yo what happened you you
supposed to be that dude what happened
what happened because he knew I was
going to be next up and then um
he was like yo FTW we can I can take you
we could do a circuit right now take it
to the chitlin circuit I can get you at
least 15 20 fights right now and then
um we can go for a championship and that
was when I was
in my 30s after you know because I went
to the gym and take my son's over there
Oscar Valdez right now is um
throwing some hella Haymakers at Lopez
um
I think uh from posture wise uh Valdez
is going to get this fight let me see
hold on
do you think Garcia will listen or do
you think they hit train like Chavez Jr
with his with the cereal
um if he doesn't listen Derek James is
not going to let his name be attached to
him Derek James would dismiss him if he
doesn't listen I think he has no choice
but to listen to Derek James
Hall of Fame Packers quarterback went to
the Jets before packing it in no pun
intended well pun intended yeah yeah
yeah
um that that's what scares me the most
Oscar Valdez is throwing Haymakers David
your pink your opinion King
in Japan how would you think Tyson would
fit today's boxing world that training
video a while back it was crazy to see
in your opinion a prime Tyson might
right now
would knock everybody out except for
Deontay Wilder
I think he beats Deontay Wilder but I
think he knocks everybody out except for
Deontay Wilder and then for Deontay
Wilder can land that right hand on top
top of Mike Tyson said that's what I
want to see I want to see
Deontay Wilder before he fought Tyson
Fury uh fight uh Prime Mike Tyson that's
the only person I think that would give
Mike Tyson any trouble right now if Mike
was to fight in this era right now he
will be Undisputed Master this of the
heavyweight championship
let me see oh Snapchat
that's what's up thanks for answering if
my charges don't make it all up to
justify me and the Super Bowl respect
respect your boxing I fought two my dads
was always had me in boxing gyms I did
kickboxing but always in boxing gym
shout out to Johnny Tapia oh that's the
homie yo Johnny Champion is a cool dude
man yo for sure
I'm out there trying to get Lopez out of
this who you have winning between Haney
and Lomo would Roy Jones be great in
this era Roy Jones to be great in any
era Roy Jones is a trans um sending
Fighter
um uh I said I got a Loma if I'm betting
my cash I got Loma I want Devin hating
to win right so I wouldn't be upset if
Denver Haney won but
um I pick Loma to win by decision right
all right so right now they're talking
to Loma
um and they're talking about breaking
punching on the break or whatever stuff
like that and he's with the referee
um let me check my phone
hold on
okay I'm just looking at my mom what my
wife text me that's all no big thing
sorry but right there they they just
talking to them and going over the rules
and the stuff like that uh in in the
background
you know I love Roy Jones too man and I
wish Roy Jones would stop fighting right
now like Roy if you're watching stop it
now
um but who am I to tell you to stop
getting your money back and teach you
how to get some money in another way bro
me and you Roy if you're watching me and
you
wigging crazy bro crazy Brett
I'm going to change
how
the podcast game is in a second I'm
going to change how it is in a second
you'll see
you'll see oh oh so Oscar Valdez is
closing distance but what I don't like
about Oscar dog does right now he's just
winning punches this is why
um uh Charlo was able to do what he did
um
I mean Shakur was able to do what he did
to him because
all he does is Wing these shots he
doesn't uh jab his way in so Shakur was
able to out box the hell out of him and
see all he does is Wing shots and and
these shots that he's winging is it's
it's
you can see them a mile away but again
if he jabbed his way in he'll be fine
Lopez is loading up on shots coming in
one two three four five shots and at a
period of time that stuff starts to
accumulate on your head so see right now
uh
Lopez is starting to jab uh Valdez out
of his shell right if anybody's watching
the fight right now so
uh Valdez is trying to cut distance
right but he's trying to cut distance
without putting the job without a get
busy uh weapon a get busy weapon is like
you you know you put a jab there and you
force the your opponent to get busy if
he's going to throw a jab if he's going
to Parry it whatever he's going to do
Valdez uh is just winging his shots
Lopez is stepping back throwing a right
hand throwing a jab when he gets in
close doing a little shoe shine stepping
off with the hook and then pivoting and
shooting the right and that's what he's
doing so those things that he's doing is
um giving Valdez trouble Valdez face is
starting to Red up right so if he
continues if Lopez continues to fight
this way and continue to do that and
evade uh valdez's winging shots then
he's going to get Valdez hell to pay
because he's moving from side to side
very good I see I see Lopez right now
feet work is good like his step back
step forward step in step out he's very
calm comfortable in the ring his hands
is in a comfortable position and he you
know he gets caught by here and there by
a punch by uh Oscar Valdez but I think
Oscar is um
used too much of his power early and
this is in the second round already and
and Valdez looks like he's a little bit
frustrated so you know Lopez is doing
his job he's doing what he's supposed to
do he you know he's boxing he needs
moving I think if Lopez had a little bit
more power then he'd give Valdez
something more to think about and I
don't think uh Valdez will just be
coming and winging in shots the way that
he is right now if Lopez had more power
Leon was good I'm good
dookie kicks I got Haney by stopping you
crazy
stoppage when's the last time Haney
stopped anybody he can't even stop his
nose from running
you mean you got you got anybody
decision
anyone remember the PlayStation camera
The Fight Night create the character
that was a great touch yeah we beat the
crap artist and look-alikes digital he
does facts
true that Benjamin
it was so good man
oh man
there we go so we're inside loma's uh
room right now so Devin Haney's jumping
rope he's trying to you know keep the
heat up and trying to warm up his body
right before the fight and I think
that's the best thing
sorry
texting the wife
remember uh margarita with a little bit
of crime but I mean um
what is a grapefruit kind of weird it
has a weird taste has a weird punch to
it
pink lemonade margarita
so um right now I happen to like I'm an
underdog type of dude all right so
Valdez is cutting distance catching um
Lopez with an overhand right Lopez
started feeling himself and he started
leaning in and he he caught uh Oscar
with a jab and an uppercut all right so
Valdez is following him around the ring
instead of cutting off the ring and I
would I would
if I was asking about this I would talk
to Julio Cesar Chavez right seniors not
junior senior to teach me how to cut the
ring off right because I see what he's
doing and he's following uh Lopez around
if your fight style is to brawl if
you're if you're a mugging brawling type
of fighter then your only recourse is to
learn how to cut off the ring and to
give a stay busy jab right so you throw
a stay busy jab out there and you cut
and you slide in but your feet your feet
there we go
so right now Oscar Valdez threw a right
hand and a left hook that caught Lopez
he's tripling up on the right hand and
Lopez is laughing with himself against
the ropes and then he Jabs Oscar to the
body and he's telling him come on oh he
hit Oscar with an uppercut and here's
some with a left hook and he's spinning
off the ropes and Oscar de Valdez
is throwing shots I Gotta Give Lopez a
lot of respect here because Lopez is
open hand and jabbing and he caught uh
Oscar Valdez and he dropped the right
hand on top of his head which uh you
know Lopez is doing what he's supposed
to do I believe Lopez is the underdog in
this fight but
um we all are when you make it to this
level you are a professional and they
all go and train just the same way right
so maybe tonight Lopez said no tonight I
want to win no tonight is about me it's
not about you and this whole uh lead up
to this fight was probably about Oscar
Valdez and what Oscar Valdez is going to
do after being outside the ring for one
year you know I just feel that you know
Lopez said tonight no and what I do love
about what Lopez has in his ability to
move is he's throwing the jab and he's
hooking off the jab and he's throwing an
uppercut off the jab and he's walking if
anybody's watching this fight this is
what I'm talking about when I said your
bottom half and your top half was
married each other when Lopez throws his
jab look where his left Lead Foot is
they mimic each other and that's the
only way that you're going to be
successful as a boxer that's why he's
able to move and get out of the way of
certain things certain Fighters can't do
that certain Fighters don't have that
they cut the ring off but that shot of
his record is suspect yeah Chavez record
is suspect yeah he fought a lot of
Tijuana cab drivers so what I'm not
saying that he isn't but he also didn't
have an amateur career don't don't tell
me that you know
um his amateur career was super
expensive because it wasn't he probably
had like 10 or 15 uh amateur fights and
then he went pro remember a lot of these
times these Mexican Fighters have to
turn pro because they need to get money
they got to feed their families it's not
like okay it's either you are doing
construction you are doing manual labor
you're doing this or you're doing that
or you're going to do this right and
Julio Cesar Chavez
um senior bless his soul found his
calling and he entertained us man I
don't think that guy ever got as much
money as he needed to get for all the
entertaining fights that he put up in
the records that he did but I guess
respect for being the lion of culiacan
the probably one of the greatest
Fighters that ever come out of Mexico
um
I guess that's uh a reward in itself
right to to as a fighter to be
recognized and revered and loved in your
home I think I think that's that's
something and respected I think that's
something to be you know Champions right
so I guess he won in in in life right if
he if he didn't win in the bank account
he won in life
all right so right now uh Oscar Valdez
and Lopez is in the center of the ring
and um Lopez is letting both hands go
while also trying to get Oscar to
um commit to shots big shots
I love how Lopez steps over I love his
step over I'm not saying that he's the
best looking boxer but what look what he
has Oscar Valdez face looking like and
he has his face looking swollen and
Lopez face looks relatively unscathed
right he's throwing he's tripling up to
jab which he just did and he dropped the
right hand over the top he stepped over
he stepped uh left and he stepped back
Oscar winged a punch to the top of the
head and Wing the punch to the body and
Lopez stepped over through three shots
and a hook and you know Lopez is right
back nice uppercut he's stepping switch
feet through an uppercut oh man I love
great boxing and Lopez is doing great
boxing at the moment if anybody's
watching the fight right now you're
getting the chance to see a good
tactician in Lopez you know he may not
be the the most known he may not be the
flashiest dude but a Lopez has boxing
skills look at his feet man beautiful
feet beautiful feet beautiful hands if
he just had a little bit more power I
think Oscar Valdez would be knocked out
by now be honest with you the same way
she called Stevenson beat him
you know I I think Lopez has a better
boxing style than uh Shakur Stevenson he
just lacks the power that Shakura has
yeah cut the ring off haha I need that
800 number you yes yes respect shopping
Devon's the only respectable power
against guys his size punching downward
at a smaller guy his Queen punches will
hurt more
dookie kicks um
we're talking about lomachenko here
we're not talking about
um
somebody that doesn't know how to Parry
slip and and dip punches and people try
to say that lomachenko doesn't know how
to slip a jab
you about to see tonight you're about to
see tonight but I mean this is what we
here for right oh snap oh
Lopez got Valdez against the ropes
working his body pause yo he was hitting
him with shots to the body like he owned
the man like he went to the meat market
and he owed them ribs dear God that was
good he was like you know what I want
ribs on the barbecue tonight and guess
who was up for service
oh Valdez Valdez excuse me this is my
ribs get out of here
Jab
they ready
it's the next fight next fight it's Loma
versus Devin Haney
oh
we about to do what we do
can't wait
but it was in the house poppy PR these
plane was good Hold the Line let's go
oh we have facts
facts man oh my God I can't wait I've
been so hyped for a lot of these boxing
matches for this year this these dudes
is doing a a wonderful favor to uh by
fighting each other all right so
now we're in round number five
all right yo yo if anybody's watching
right now if anybody's watching they
must have told Lopez go out there and
start boxing his ears off
this kid got boxing skills I don't care
what nobody says Lopez I got boxing
skills he's letting his hands go one two
three four five he's in the middle of
the Ring right now with Valdez Valdez
catches him with a left hook all right
but Lopez goes right back to the jab and
he's he's taller than uh Valdez
and he turns Valdez and he punches him
with a right hand Left Foot Right Hand
yo I'm telling you right now Lopez looks
like a smaller version of David
benavidez right without the power and
David benavidez can box but this kid
right here got some skills on him I'm
I'm a fan now I'm really turning into a
fan of of Lopez
really good oh that uppercut was crazy
but Valdez caught him with that right
hand
and he's pressuring him he's pressing
them he's pressing them all right he's
he's trying to cut this is all right so
Valdez catches uh Lopez and Lopez steps
to the left step to the right goes back
to the jab they back in the center of
the Ring he faints him a couple of times
goes low to the body and he walks in on
him and he's throwing four or five shots
he's jabbing him and then he's shooting
the right stab and low uh Valdez to the
stomach Valdez is back up against the
ropes Lopez is coming in dipping faint
and throws an uppercut pushes him off
throws a right hand throws a left hook
right here jab steps over one two one
two one two three Oscar Valdez get mad
throws a slap and left hook
Lopez catches him again Lopez looking
good baby I gotta respect it step in he
feigned him he's fainting him out of his
socks oh for cut oh Lopez I'm a fan
straight to the body the rib game is
crazy good job hand stepping over yeah
oh he's moving the hand over close over
close that's what's up now he's on his
bicycle stepping back ask off out there
his face looks like he he got a BBL on
his cheeks is crazy
Lopez is turning him he's turning him
he's spinning him he's turning them it's
like a top with a right hand and he just
drops that right hand on the side of his
face oh my God an uppercut oh the left
hook is crazy Lopez is doing his thing
one two three the feet look good the boy
looking like he in his prime oh my God
Valdez is trying Lopez is sliding in
coming in chasing him it looks crazy he
goes right back to the job we got 10
seconds left for the round seven six
five four three two one Lopez looks
crazy that kid got boxes scales man I'm
telling you man like no other that can
look good
let me see let me see you're going Josh
tell it to your female watchlock yeah
yeah I'm gonna do that I got Josh Taylor
beating uh till Fimo I'm thinking when I
think uh I think Lohman is is a little
past his prime what's good King B low
what's good
fun speculation what's good man yo map
you going viral they said I gotta get
you a Ghost Rider uh I like what you did
anyway regardless everything was good
production by math math did work man put
that in That's What I Love Thinking
Outside the Box I tell him watch the
video earlier you see
yo I'ma tell you right now Lopez is
doing his thing honestly I gotta respect
that I'm a huge fan of a person that
puts in that work that is is defeat is
the marriage of feet and hands is that
to know how and Lopez is pulling
together everything that I love about
boxing all right so we're in round six
and Lopez is moving on him he's snotting
on him he's switching positions with his
feet he's fainting him so much he's
putting constant pressure on Oscar
Valdez and Oscar Valdez is the one
that's doing the salkin but Lopez looks
like he's the one that's the most
comfortable in this whole fight right so
look at this man there's no way in hell
they're saying Oscar Valdez threw more
punches than Lopez and Lopez just threw
like 10 punches right there this is
ridiculous man the fix is in your boy
has to get this a knockout I respect
Lopez I want Lopez to continue to do
what he's doing because I respect true
boxing in all forms but this boy right
here looks good man sweet science
satisfying this man
fantastic oh
yeah Oscar dude Oscar Valdez just you
know through a left hook to try to take
his head off but you know
Lopez is back on the jab back on the
grind you know all he has to do is just
swirl his head up nice step in right
hand from uh Lopez Oscar Valdez uh try
to throw a couple of punches left hook
right hand and Lopez got out of there
again uh Valdez doesn't know how to cut
the ring off right and you know Lopez
being at his foot game is so good uh
he's walking uh Lopez I mean Valdez back
to the ropes while Lopez is throwing uh
hooks to the body hooks to the head and
right hands they spin off their back to
the center of the ring you know I didn't
expect to call this fight yeah I really
didn't I thought we was going to talk
about something else but again at the
same time Lopez is doing this thing and
this is when you know great fights make
you want to call a fight because you're
watching something that's different
something that's not the same something
that's incredible and this boy is
incredible boy I'm gonna tell you right
now this jab is beautiful look at that
jab he stepping he moved
Valdez doesn't know when he wants to
throw because Lopez doesn't give him the
ability to know what he wants to do next
Lopez has given him so many different
angles oh Lopez looks like
if anybody has watched uh uh Pepino
Cuevas or or were Fido Benitez uh
he he has that style that beautiful
style that beautiful Hispanic style it's
like he has the Rhythm inside his head
he's he's listening to Bachata inside
his head he's listening to merengue
inside his head he's stepping over he's
throwing the hands he's throwing a right
he's throwing a left and he's and he's
doing exactly what he's supposed to do
his body is telling him how to fight
this fight you saw what he just did he
punched he pointed to the floor and
punched Valdez in his face 10 seconds
left in the round I'm not gonna lie
Lopez has made me a fan and Lopez is
being aggressor with Oscar Valdez going
to the back of the ropes
he has asked about this thoroughly
frustrated I will be frustrated too if
this dude was styling on me the way that
he's styling on Valdez
great video man what up King what up
Corey think outside the box look for
those wrecked Angels paying attention
that's what's up
he's in full Rhythm that's right that's
what I'm talking about Benjamin
it's like yo the style that he's using
on him is crazy the style that he's
using on him stepping on them moving on
them moving over to the left moving over
to the right pulling him forward pushing
back
fantastic boxing and I'm not gonna lie
he's he's doing it all he's displaying
it excuse me
he got to win man if it goes the
distance he gotta win
because
um Valdez isn't doing everything he's
supposed to do
to neutralize this man
they got a packed house right now
Luma versus Haney I don't think the
pay-per-view does the numbers that they
wanted to do but again this is something
for legacy so
so here we go
They're Gonna Keep they're going to keep
disrespecting lomachenko until
lomachenko show them what's up all right
so right now
um Lopez is circling to uh valdez's
Power hand all right and then Lopez goes
in for one two three and he starts
walking Valdez back right and Valdez
leaps in with a uh Power jab and he's
power jabbing uh stepping in so he's
stepping in with a power jab but Lopez
is taunting him stepping over to the
left stepping over to the right shooting
the jab all right and he dipped slow and
he steps back Valdez swings and misses
uh Lopez clinches to the referee breaks
them they're breaking the center of the
Ring Lopez goes right back to jabbing
jab strong jab strong jab up top bottom
the varying levels of his jab is crazy
he's able to give you different levels
of his jab he goes here here here here
here here here so you don't know what to
cover up
oh okay Valdez catches him with two
sharp uh left Hooks and Lopez steps back
resets goes right back to the jab
um Lopez is uh bringing uh Valdez closer
stepping in stepping out and Valdez
Swings with a left hook and he misses
swing with the right hand and he misses
Lopez goes right back to the jab Valdez
land is a left to his body lands a right
to the top lands a left to the liver
Valdez does and Valdez doesn't know the
left hook but he misses and um
Lopez goes right back to jabbing
you know he's jabbing to the top he's
jabbing to the middle and uh Lopez
continues to do so then the center of
the Ring Valdez throws a hook to the
body of Lopez Lopez spins him literally
spins him and then Lopez is on the
attack Lopez goes from head to body to
head to body right hand over the top he
steps in he steps back he goes right
back to the jab so Valdez has a lot to
worry about uh Lopez still is a nice
right hand through the guard of Lopez I
mean Valdez and he shoots the Jab
very good very good Lopez keeps fainting
and Oscar Valdez catches him with a
right hand and a left hook a right hand
by Oscar Valdez and Lopez spins and
throws a right hand left hook
good uh left hook by of Lopez Lopez got
Oscar Valdez against the ropes he's
pushing him up against the ropes left
hook to the body uppercut right hand
Lopez is pushing Oscar Valdez back and
he's going to his body Oscar Valdez is
holding uh Lopez is working Oscar Valdez
with crazy shots I'm telling you we're
looking at a fighter that is uh not to
be deterred tonight he's being he's
becoming something more than what he's
supposed to be and I gotta respect him
Lopez is doing his thing
bone slave what's good Cali loved it's
in the building
what's going on we're in round seven
going to eight Lopez might drop Valdez
yeah heated heavy things and that's what
you can find it's free online if you if
you want to watch there you go do that
show them show them give them the link
give them the link Ben
my patreon about to be lit
about to make something happen we about
to make something happen boom boom I'm
going to Pax West
September we'll be in Seattle baby
cargo B and L.A Attica B in La for E3
and the Kegley jump
um I'll be in play NYC
and uh
um with uh uh Lord Petey we'll be
covering the play NYC definitely gotta
fill out those paperwork too so
that's dope
oh good job good job from uh
Valdez oh Lopez spins throws one two
Lopez throws a 1-2
Lopez steps over one two three Lopez
back in the middle
all right oh my God he's being so
disrespectful this kid is nice man all
right so y'all see right there he's he's
given various levels to his jab and he
steps over and he brings it right back
and he's telling uh Valdez to follow him
in and he's throwing Jabs
right look at that Valdez wants to
engage but Lopez is giving him positions
he's switching Styles too Lopez is
switching from Southport are Orthodox
from Southport Orthodox on them and uh
I've never seen Valdez this befuddled
even when he fought Shakur Stevenson
I've never seen them this befuddled you
know it's kind of crazy
yeah
this is nuts
listen look at that look at that this is
crazy
good job
all right so right back to one two one
two from uh Lopez
all right so he's turning them
and he's hitting them
very good
Lopez oh step in uppercut that was good
he slips under Oscar Valdez Oscar throws
a lot of [__] and then oh that body shot
hurt that body shot hurt that body shot
hurt that body shot hurt if this guy can
hear me my guy yo that body shot heard
Valdez all right so uh Lopez spun and
threw a right hand to the hip and then
in the kidney area of um of Valdez and
Valdez felt that
so good jab right hand this is crazy
um
Valdez boy
so right now Lopez is turning them
and they just broke up uh the referee
broke them up
right back to jabbing
oh he has a cut does that a cut over his
eye
oh nice uppercut nice uppercut from
Lopez
Lopez is guarding good guard uh guard
move all right so what he's doing is
he's jabbing so when he's guarding his
Guardians keeping his hand up so he can
catch so he can catch some pictures and
punch you catching your hand and you
pinch right back at him Lopez is feeling
himself I'm gonna tell you right now
Lopez is dancing around the ring Lopez
is giving him everything this this this
is that's that's what you want to do as
a boxer
between round what do you think about
um MK trailer what up King Lord
Supremacy what's up um Lopez is winning
you can get about anything
um let me see
um the Mortal Kombat trailer I wanted to
see gameplay right the game looks nice
did it do for me like the first time I
ever saw Mortal Kombat when I saw the
digitized fighters hell no
that looked crazy I mean to this day
that it still looks wild nuts the
animations is stunted it looks weird
it looks nuts uh something like when it
took it took it to 3D
it looked good it looks great does it
look real no it doesn't look real I mean
just
it's it's it's something it's it's it's
it's it's a barrier there's something
there they have to do a new technology
to actually give you that that moment
that dropped dead moment but does it
look better than all the Mortal Kombats
that came after
um besides the first one take the first
real Mortal Kombat and put that to the
side right and you have like um I say
Mortal Kombat two or three on when they
went away from digitized
yeah
um this is probably the best looking one
so far hopefully we get to the point
where they look like the movie actors
and it looks really that good but
they're close it looks real good
excuse me am I going to have a great
time with it yes
definitely
um this is the year of the fighter
oh left hook right hand from Oscar
Valdez
this is the best thing that he's done in
a long time
um when the ninth round is a tenth round
fight but Lopez throws a one two three
and he stops the charge of Oscar Valdez
with the triple left
and he steps over and he throws a right
hand
let me see what you got going on here
remember when they made blood white for
this Super Nintendo yeah it was called
sweat yeah that OG was crazy in arcade
it sure was yeah Johnny Cash
lomachenko can pull us off Vegas is
wallowing with that line hell yeah if
you want to make some money bet on
lomachenko
you got fifty dollars to lose win or
whatever
better lomachenko
it was this this fight right now has
turned into
if Lopez can get to the distance right
now
I don't see how uh Oscar Valdez can win
Oscar Valdez is landing shots now he's
winging he's going for broke he's going
for broke but Lopez needs to beat back
Oscar Valdez
yeah
yeah he has to uh
you know um
you you know uh Lopez has to jab his way
through Valdez is still trying to win
he threw a left hook and he's winging
shots right now I'm not gonna say ask
about this is not winging shots ask
about this is winging shots but Lopez
needs to do a little bit more
um
I'm watching what Lopez is doing I think
he's taking his round off I wouldn't
have took the round off per se he only
got two rounds to go and right there see
he um you get you get to the point where
you're so late in the fight and you
start to take round off and you spin and
Valdez catches you with a couple of
shots and he starts to get a second win
you don't want to give a veteran fighter
any type of courage or any type of Hope
right you want to continue to demoralize
them have them
feel like he's defeated have him feel
like this isn't his night
you don't give him the opportunity to
feel like oh he has one less one last
burst left him
but that doesn't mean we're winning this
fight King yeah that'd be crazy too
facts but I I bet early cash or money
MK animation is close to the clay
animation looking totally breaks the
illusion low key this is true yo dookie
kicks nothing wrong with make a killer
action figure fighting game
I need to make some money who you got
along I got Loma
let me tell you right now it's gonna be
a good fight Loma is a plus 250. I don't
care what you doing take the take the 50
dollars
embedded if you got fifty dollars the
better you got a hundred dollars to bet
you got something that you can't that
you don't care about losing go better
right go go bet it better better than
the underdog this is this is the as much
of a 50 50 fight as you're going to get
and me personally I 50 50 choose
lomachenko
I mean I love Devin Haney I want Devin
Haney to win but if I'm betting Brad
betting cash
why because he lost the teal female
no
uh no conventional wisdom says Loma has
lost already Devin Haney has never lost
Devin Haney and lomachenko has not
fought the same level of competition all
right um y'all can sit here and say
cambosis is that dude cambosis is not
that dude you know Tio Fimo is not that
dude oh
Oscar Valdez broke his nose
broke his nose
Lopez got a dip out now boy that's what
I told you
that right hand he broke his nose and
Valdez can get this oh man Lopez is on
his bicycle Valdez is trying to finish
him yo look at the blood streaming down
this dude face you want to talk about a
shot from Heaven this dude said
[Music]
straight to the damn nose
boy you better fight you better let your
face go numb let your face go numb
you better just get it you better bite
down man hold the line boy
don't
take it like
fight boy fight there you go you fight
you stay close you fight you tell him
hell no I don't care if he broke your
nose you fight you you train too hard
for this you sit there you fight Valdez
is coming pause
yeah man
if that was ahead button that's crazy
that's crazy
come on Lopez oh oh oh
Lopez is about to get knocked out Valdez
is Autumn he tackled up he tackle about
this
hey yo
come on Yo shades of Julio Caesar Chavez
I invoke this name
uh it's boy stay up on them shades of
Julio Caesar Chavez versus Mildred
Taylor
you better go ahead man go ahead fake to
the top and go there you go fake to the
top and go to the body Valdez you need
to learn how to cut off the ring this is
the problem right now 10 seconds left
Valdez is uh he slipped
shouldn't have pushed him shouldn't have
pushed them shouldn't have pushed them
shouldn't have pushed him if he didn't
push him you would have had more time
so yo y'all right y'all might get that
Valdez Split Decision
meant to be broken
that was a hell of a good fight man
that was a hell of a good fight boy
you want to talk about
oh it was a headboard
[Music]
yo it was a head bump wow
boom if that dude don't get knocked out
by that he has a chin of God yo I got I
can't front boy
boy you tackle that man
you tackle that man
that that was a good fight man that was
a good fight that was a good fight
that was a good fight
headboard gang yo for real you want to
talk about a headboard on God Valdez
definitely did his thing boy he came up
yo hit him with the head bump boom
through that left hook right over the
top some mocking day as soon as he hit
him with the headbunt smocking thing
right over the top
that was good that was good
really good that was a really good fight
I'm not gonna front no cap that was a
good fight you gotta respect it but I
mean I I love Adam Lopez I thought Adam
Lopez did such a great job such a
wonderful job
um showing a great account of himself
you know but
house fighter is uh Oscar Valdez all
right
um so remember he's promoted by top rank
uh
you never know you never know
um I've seen egregious uh
losses and and wins so you never know
you know I I truly expect uh it to be a
split decision uh is but but it's gonna
probably be a split decision of going
for Oscar Valdez
even though Lopez gave a great Academy
encounter himself
hold on let's get this
98-92
98 91 98-91
97-93
the wow
those call cards were so far apart
this dude would have had to
knock him down seven times in the last
round in order to even cover
that's that's disrespectful I would have
gave him a split decision if anything
you know
uh no Split Decision
wow that's crazy right
um
no one's friends
you seem rejuvenated those 13 months off
I'm gonna tell you right now he fights
anybody with anybody with a form of
power that has the same foot movement as
Adam and um he's not gonna survive
he's not gonna survive that's just
facts facts of it you know he's not
going to survive
well we have Loma versus Henny next
Henny
this is going to be something crazy I
first of all let me tell you something I
never thought I was going to see this
fight
um the fact that Devin Haney uh decided
that he wants to defend his titles
against lomachenko
um
that shows you what type of champion he
is because he didn't have to do this uh
it wasn't like he was a mandatory for
anything
uh I think uh who who's his mandatory I
think uh tank is his mandatory and I
think Shakur is his mandatory right
um
I don't think Lomas is mandatory so the
fact that he fought Luma
that's that shows what type of champion
he is but at the same time
we uh
sometimes you pick wrong you know
sometimes your your mindset is that you
feel that you can beat this guy and you
felt that you can beat this guy all the
way through and you got the belts
without even having to go through that
guy and then it's your turn to fight and
then
you say you know what let me go get that
guy that I didn't get a chance to fight
I don't know it could be a mistake
but we're gonna find out
could have been a mistake but we're
gonna find out
that is made drop a Honda on Loma let's
go phase
phase that's what's up not your dumbass
who you got in the main wait what Lopez
deserve better that's true
I I personally believe Lopez deserve
better
all right so Devin Haney right now is
um
he's doing some mitts in the back
Loma is already warm
um I love the fact that um
Loma his father put his put his son in
um ballet class
very early on
because he understood for his son to be
here
he had to have that Foundation
and that Foundation was uh steeped in um
in ballerina
and and and foot movement and then he uh
does out the box uh training with his
hands
you know
um
it's it's a nice
pairing of the two and and for his
father to recognize that very early on
uh to have him go move your feet move
your hands and you you all see the thing
that Loma does um he does a uh it's like
a um a reaction test right and and it
lights up on the wall it's the lights
and it goes from the green red dots and
he hits the dots on the wall and you
have to hit the dots and then he also
does the the ping pong thing and he has
the Hat with the ball on it
um he does a lot of things that are uh
keep your eyes sharp and it's a lot of
stuff that let baseball players do
he does different things that's not
traditional in boxing and he carries
those things over into the boxing Rings
that's what made him so successful
he's
the consummate professional right
lomachenko when it comes to boxing
and Devin Haney does traditional boxing
things
and it's going to be the battle of the
unconventional versus the conventional
and old school unconventional new school
conventional
youth
versus experience I think strength is on
Loma side
versus
length
pause
the length because Devin Haney has at
least I think it's like five inches of
reach
over lomachenko and that's that
sometimes that's insurmountable that
that much distance is insurmountable for
a fighter to overcome but I think uh
lomachenko can overcome that distance
with the distance in the jab uh and in
the right hand I think he can cut
distance and force Haney to fight on the
inside if Haney can fight on the inside
I think then Luma has no shot
but my my prediction is only based off
of the fact that
uh previous fights and how Devin Haney
is truly uncomfortable with fighting on
the inside and lomachenko is truly
comfortable with fighting on the inside
uh and lomachenko is not averse to
fighting on distance but he doesn't he
has a shorter arm so it's not his uh
wheelhouse
so you can get Toe to Toe Loma going to
slip the disc in his back trying to slip
him yo dookie kicks you crazy
not a dog horse but a Black Swan are you
stupid
punishment is coming I wonder if the
main event will start earlier one day
say 11 p.m eastern time the latest
height wasn't much of a distance
compared to the t05
it's interesting as the main fight
started yet no the main fight didn't
start yet but it's getting ready to
start
um
yeah main event started earlier before
you know if you had dudes on your
undercard that was knocking people out
and then you had to go into okay so what
how fight cards are structured right you
have
um the prelims
then you have the main card the main
card is usually three fights right then
you have the three fights and then you
know then the main
if any of those two fights
go one round let's say both of those
those two fights goes one round you
cannot have because of sponsors and the
way that your time slot is you cannot
have that main event fight go before the
initial time in which the sponsors need
to get paid right the sponsors need to
have enough viewership in front of your
eyes
so what they do is they have ready
Fighters that's in the back right and
those ready Fighters they'll call them
up like yo listen you've been called now
sometimes those ready Fighters don't get
to fight those are standby Fighters they
don't get to fight
I've never been a sam5 standby fighter
so
I don't know if they get paid I don't
know anything
um let me uh mute this
right now because they're gonna be doing
the Nets from Anthem and stuff like that
and coming to the ring uh with stuff so
right now they have the Ukrainian
um national anthem she's uh the singer
is singing it right now and you know
they have the flag up so
we don't want to get uh flag for this
but um yeah
so we have those they have uh get busy
Fighters as that's in the back and then
those Fighters if they fight I don't
know if they get paid or not or whatever
but those Fighters uh will step in to
give distance to the main event so
don't think that it's just whatever
scheduled and then if those fights
happen to get a knockout let's say the
Oscar Valdez fight ended in the first
round knockout
they would have had another fight after
that unscheduled on the card
I wonder if Nico won uh Muhammad Ali's
son I gotta check that
I got to work at a m and the fight won't
start until early 12 A.M
yeah
this is true
Dolph Kermit what's good
Focus was good
yeah so right now as soon as they're
finished
get back to the crowd yeah get back to
hearing the crowd noise lomachenko's in
the back right now and he's walking
pacing
good camera stuff
I was looking at early Mike Tyson fights
this week and
especially when him fighting my boy
Mitch
I always like watching that fight
because in that fight you had a prime
Tyson and in that fight you had a prime
Mitch Green and yeah I believe Mike
Tyson got the best of my screen
obviously he got the decision but
Mitch gave as much as he got in that
fight and um
it was good to see but you know I I
don't think Mike had more fun than in
that fight if y'all go back and watch
Mitch Green versus Mike Tyson and
Madison Square Garden
I'm somewhere in the stands
um
the way he's slipping
Mike is having such a good time in that
ring he's so free in that fight I don't
think he's ever been that free in a
fight
then when he was fighting Mitch Green
because
the talk going into that fight
the huge conversations that was going
into that fight
Mitch was talking so much crap and um
Mike just wanted to shut him up so bad
I might got a chance to do it right now
they're singing the the
um
the United States uh national anthem the
USA national anthem and um I don't know
who that singer is but uh that's almost
over
you know the show Devin Haney
and
we're almost Gonna Be Live
so again anybody bet on Loma
if if we got a knockout one round and
who
if we get a knockout what round and who
if we get a knockout my choice would be
Loma by 10th round knockout
if we get a knockout
but
if not then
who
you got somebody got Devin Haney by
knockout
that'll be interesting to see
hmm
let's see
all right
and it's over right now you know that
but that place is packed that place is
packed here we go he has a Muhammad Ali
shirt standing over Sonny Liston
I mean I yo
oh
it's time
it's time it's time it's time it's time
got plus two uh stingy boogie that's
what's up
oh he had a draw Nico had a draw
let me see finally thoughts we got a
hundred dollars online but Benji's got a
benjies on it
here we go King David what's going on a
cute perspective
due respect brother in New York City all
day love
40 that's in the building hopefully we
got 40 likes I didn't even check the
likes
to to whatchamacola right now
you know uh bet Whatchamacallit bet ngn
is on right now
all right we got 35 likes oh I didn't
even put a like in there oh no we got 56
likes 57 likes here we go there go my
like there you go
all right here we go guys the MGM Grand
yo the home of the greats
I mean Mike Tyson I think Mike Tyson
made the MGM Grand right or was it
um
or was it Floyd
I don't know one of the two made the MGM
Grand
and opened it and and and did everything
this is for Undisputed right now
we got tank versus Ryan Garcia that
happened already
we gonna have Loma versus honey
that's happening right now we're gonna
have Tio Fimo versus Josh that's gonna
happen
hopefully hopefully if Bud stop ducking
we can get Spence
versus Bud
and on everything I love I'm betting the
grand on Spence
on everything I love I own back but I'm
a bet on that fight because I want to
see Bud get knocked the hell out cold
I don't like the fact people ducking
let's go
you know I hit the like brother hit the
like right before he was sure that's
what's up that's my dude thank you this
right
hook hit the like let's go
tell him heated heavy Four Kings part
two
this is this is it man you guys should
call Stevenson you got Devin Haney you
you have Ryan Garcia I don't think Ryan
Garcia's chapter is done man uh listen
if Loma Chango wins right now is
lombachenko in the mix
do we get a chance to see lomachenko
versus tank
does tank get the chance to come in
there and just knock a little machenko
out and take all three of those I mean
all four of those belts
what's up or the Shakura fight
lomachenko
do we get a chance to see that
this is it right here man
lomachenko 17 two draws and 11 knockouts
what happens man MGM Grand looks
beautiful in Vegas
you got Jared Anderson
14-0 with 14 knockouts right you got
favor Flav there people keep on thinking
Flavor Flav broke flavor flavor not
broke boy y'all gotta respect that man
Emilio Rivera is in the building
oh please oh Michael Jai White's always
around his beautiful wife is next to him
Mark Davis looks crazy like yo he looks
like um The Three Stooges if one of the
Three Stooges has got just grew up looks
crazy
Mark Mark Wahlberg don't play man he's
at every fight man I know that dude had
fun I know he had fun
this is for boxing let's go play with
slave just look broke I like me yo you
stupid
Mark Davis bowl cut wow you're for real
spawn in the house love and Chica
walking down there by himself oh god
let's get it he walking he walking down
the hallway dolo
oh man
who's in the building Depot's in the
building
said uh
you didn't worry about me until I put on
the mask
who am I
I was born in the darkness raised in it
usually adopted it
up
he says solo jinko
boy look like he ready to take care of
some bitties you know some business he's
standing on business
your boy's standing on business
yeah I know man I know man I know listen
I know
we don't give our American boxers the
respect especially in the iPhone
American boxes of respect by standing
behind them and you know putting country
and flag and all that stuff behind them
and I guess something that's something
that we used to and that's a deficiency
as us As Americans
but as me as a boxer
I love the way this guy boxes
I must say
this guy gets busy
pulse
what up King what up message
this is it I had my son walking around
upstairs
that's my youngest son not not not not
my uh a mother son Brenda my middle son
that's my youngest son
that's Dante
named after
Dante from Devil May Cry
I love that game love Devil May Cry
I'm a patriot but you gotta go with the
True Grit
I got handed by split
yo
you gotta respect Haney for
what he's able to accomplish he goes to
Australia
yo
lomachenko walked out there dolo solo
for real no Entourage no nothing nothing
fancy nothing nothing no glitch no
glamor
um I think that lost to tell Fimo change
this man in in a profound way
we gonna see tonight we're gonna see
tonight
we're gonna see tonight
but we are here and we are doing this
together
we got 38 strong watching that's what's
up
all right here we go
here we go Devin Haney's walking out
dolo solo too
he got the Bone Crusher suit on that's
what's up
you see me rolling
no no no that's that's that's that's not
Bone Crusher Bone Crusher is to pop that
trunk and the outside of the club and
they think I'm a pawn
right
here
oh here we go
that looked nice though I mean yo top
ring look nice they're looking like
remember how HBO used to do they things
you know they they it looks it looks it
looks like how HBO used to do it I mean
maybe they probably have all the old
production dudes from HBO because HBO
folded up their tennis when they
couldn't get uh Triple G to beat
um Canelo
so
let's go
no I said I'll come out with Bone
Crusher that or 50 Cent I'll whip your
head boy
you know I will or or or some some King
Von John
um I don't know uh
you know I definitely won't come out
with uh fpg duck sliding uh definitely
uh crazy story King Von probably do that
I don't know one of the two one or two
well definitely but uh yeah for sure
definitely
you know 50 Cent whip your head
we got some good stuff oh oh what's
what's that what's that new trick now uh
Scarlet you know
instead of f out New York that joint
that joint fire too I like that right
now or probably some Jadakiss joint so
Mount Vernon love shout out to the the
locks
let me see what we got going on there
rest in peace HBO for real HBO
definitely we got 47 in here that means
if you knew what you're gonna do you're
gonna hit that like button you're gonna
hit that subscribe and you're definitely
going to tune in for what we're about to
bring you cause we're about to bring you
something that you have never seen
before
something that you've never seen before
nobody's going to call a fight like me
you got dudes calling a fight but they
ain't gonna call a fight like me
they're gonna tell you what happened
after the fact I'm gonna tell you what's
gonna happen while you're watching it
taking you back in the days back when
you had to listen to it on radio
come out with the spares
Hit Me Baby One More Time now I'm
kidding but cut that out
yo yo it's still setting up
it's Brittany
Hit Me Baby One More Time
nah oh that's not the song that you want
to see when you box it hit me baby one
more time
nah buddy that's it we ain't gonna do
that right
lomachenko looking mad as hell boy
looking like you mess with somebody
money
ah this is gonna be funny just wanted to
see you live brother thank you good
times all day always all day always
always smiling have a good time if I
come out I come out with Marc Anthony
brother
Puerto Rico
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude
yo you're ridiculous man y'all are some
ridiculous dude
PR 100 facts though
facts though
uh-uh
I'ma come out to
flow
it's a flaw
hell yeah
there we go
electricity
lightning it's looking good they putting
this together for these boys man
this is this is Yo
top rank doing their thing
no sleeping man
oh man they said the Bud Light Blue
corner
35 years old five seven 135 pounds
two-time Olympic gold medalists
former three division world champion
thirteen and two and nine
oh
lomachenko looking upset boy like you
don't kick this puppy did you kick his
puppy
did you kick his puppy and steal his car
sound like something that they did to
John Wick you went too far baby
oh you don't set this man off baby he
looking like a man on fire baby
remember when I finish finish it fast
and went in the early rounds man we
never know woof we never know wolf we
got 51 head man hit that like [__] out
we bout to get busy we bout to get busy
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about good fight
do this to you good fight have you
popping
called them the Matrix for a reason
it's Matrix season they're saying U6
mandatory's Wilder but Fury is trying to
take trying to get back in the mix which
fights with where I make
um usak versus Deontay Wilde is a
dangerous fight for usek
he should fight Fury if it's for the
championship for all the belts fight
Fury
and and go for history right
all right so we have uh Devin Haney to
age 24 height five nine weight three
four
one thirty four point nine
you looking all right
you looking ready he's bouncing on both
feet
let's go
dude I'm so happy about this fight I
can't wait you ain't the only one my
fight music will re Return of the Dragon
intro music
I think like water
you must be
like water it takes the form of the
glass
let's go
hey me
yo why they always put blue versus red
you ain't see that low my hair blue and
Haney had red and they got the blue
versus red and I was just watching uh
Disney plus watching Visions two uh with
the with the Sif blue versus red
uh-oh lomo's bouncing
this is looking good
this is good touched in
looking good
round one we bout to get it yeah that's
effing go phase let's do it face
let's do it got 50 watching let's go
here we go Undisputed
Luma got the short shorts let's go
all right
so Devin is cutting distance coming over
loma's backing up so what we said can uh
Loma fight on his back foot and can
Devin Haney fight on his front foot
let us see
all right
Devin Haney throws a jab he throws a
right hand to the body
Devin going right to loma's body
nice jab from Devin
all right
all right the tone
Devin going straight to loma's body
loma's dipping showing faints
Devin
is keeping his jab hand in Loma throws a
jab
and dips over
Loma
is coming over
throws a right hand
I mean a left hand another left hand to
the head of uh Haney
all right
Devin's throwing his jab he's keeping
his jab out there
and he's trying to keep Loma in front of
him Loma is spending them giving them a
lot of ring this ring is very very big
very very big
Loma is moving from side to side giving
great lateral moving jabbing uh Devin
Haney is giving lateral movement jabbing
nobody's landed anything you know Devin
Haney throws a triple Loma is in range
zero Devon didn't tie him up and Devin
is throwing shots when Loma gets close
that's something different that I've
never seen he's trying to do something
that he's never done to begin something
that he's never been and this is
fantastic
all right so normal switches
and he sends close
bowl for fighting inside but there's
nothing being thrown heavy yet
Loma is leaning on Devin's neck and
Devin's trying to bring his head up he
couldn't bring his head up that doesn't
bode well
all right very very early on all right
so lomachenko has landed Two Shots Devin
Haney is going right back under the rib
cage
nice job from Devin Devin throws a jab
right hand lomachenko is sliding he's
given mad distance Devin is shooting the
right hand
and
uh-huh lomachenko is leaning on Devin's
neck what he's trying to do is trying to
take the movement out of Devon's legs
all right so Loma is stalking Devin
and Loma is pressing he lands one two
three four
and Loma wins the first round we have a
super chat from Jason two dollar suit
three dollar Super Chat holding the line
champ Haney on points I don't think so I
think you're gonna be upset fight music
okay you're really gonna make me unleash
the dragons
[Laughter]
you crazy yes sir short shorts get the
Shorties if Loma can start early he's
got a chance and he has if he can't
assalamualaikum my brother couldn't miss
another combat talk hard to find
blessings my brother thank you alaikum
Salaam
oh
nice left [__] he landed on the side of
lomachenko's head
Loma right hand under
um
very very very good first round but I
gotta get at the lomachenko man I might
be a little bit biased baby
according to comedybox each man landed
six punches oh so that round should be a
watch
all right so
right now Devin Haney is uh on his front
foot
and lomachenko is
trying to um push uh Devin Haney back so
now lomachenko is giving distance
showing shoulders showing faints and he
keeps leaning towards Devin Haney's
power hand and he goes straight to the
body uh Devin Haney does on lomachenko
he throws uh right hand to the body and
throws a right hand to the Head
lomachenko throws one two punches and
leans on Devon's neck devons needs to
stop having lomachenko leaned on his
neck I don't I don't think that's gonna
Bowl well for Devin Haney and his legs
later
all right so
good job but lomo's not allowing Devin
Haney to push him off his swear
lomachenko is right there Devin Haney
goes to the body lomachenko's in the
center of the Ring Devin throws a jab
and a hook
all right and they're both in the center
of the Ring Lomo is pushing pushing and
he keeps leaning Devon into the same
left hand and he keeps pushing Devin
throws a right hand over the top towards
left uh Loma jab right hand towards the
body good Haney got that left hook to
the body that should definitely take
something out of loma's legs Paloma
pushes Devin Haney goes right back to
the body Haney is not grabbing Haney is
not holding he's throwing this uppercut
and his uppercut is very dangerous to
Loma oh that uppercut is crazy from uh
Devin Haney but lomachenka lands uh four
or five shots and he has uh Devin in the
back and he bounces off for Devin and he
lands you know four or five shots he
bounces back
Jabs
this is a very good fight so far I think
lomachenko and Devin Haney is definitely
doing everything that they can do we're
seeing both of them fight in the
uncomfortable spots uh Devin Haney as
far as him fighting forward and
lomachenko fighting backing up this is
kind of crazy this is something of a
Revolt reversal lomachenko keeps uh
Matador in him
Devin Haney keeps going to lomachenko's
body and lomachenko keeps throwing the
right hand to Devin Haney's head
nice left hook to Devin Haney's head
lomachenko
keeps oh left hook right hand and huh
and Devin Haney keeps digging under
armor machenko's body uh-huh
lomachenko is keep pushing Devin Haney
Landing four or five shots at the end of
the round
very good high pressured round very hard
to to to score if I was going to score
that round I would score that round of
draw because I felt that Devin Haney
landed a bunch of uppercuts
landed a lot of left Hook's right hands
violent chest AKA boxing Loma is hitting
him like he stole something that's on
God Loma definitely got the first round
ain't he touching the body now his boxes
in bunches from Loma yeah it's a tie the
first round I mean the second round was
the tie that was a good round that was
definitely a good round from both
individuals I can't lie loma's listening
to his pops right now and his pops is
explaining exactly what he wants him to
do you know um
but I believe both of the fighters know
uh the tendency of the other fighter and
Devin Haney is surprising me he's not
tying him up all right so normally Devin
Haney ties up he's not tying up
he's throwing an uppercut and I guess
he's learning that from Floyd that body
shot was crazy
all right so here we go so we back in
the third round right now and he rounds
is us coming in so okay so what I see
right now in round number three Loma is
still moving on his toes and Devin Haney
is still keeping a tight guard coming in
slipping under coming over Devin Haney
is throwing the jab uh lomachenko is
jabbing and stepping over
all right so
lomachenko is still moving on the
outside Devin Haney is still going to
the body Devin Haney is throwing the
uppercut to the body I don't know at
what point in time does Loma decide to
go to Devin Haney's head when he throws
that uppercut
mm-hmm
right hand counter from uh Devin Haney
over the top lomachenko spins and
they're back in the center of the Ring
uh lomachenko is giving a lot of faints
Devin Haney is shooting the right hand
all right
good jab from uh Devin Haney lomachenko
throws a right hand over the top and
tries to catch Devin Haney Devin Haney
goes right back to the jab lomachenko
throws uh two left hooks inside Devin
Devin Haney is holding and hitting
um
they broke him up and they're back in
the center of the ring uh lomachenko
lands a strong uh left hand on the head
of Devin Haney and he's uh lomachenko is
pushing down the Haney to the ropes and
lemon lomachenko is back on Devin
Haney's neck and then the center to the
ring
and now they're punching while they're
holding both of them
in the center of the Ring
so lomachenko throws the jab Devin Haney
throws that same uppercut to the body
and lomachenko is inside that uppercut
to the body from Devin Haney is nice
over the overhand right left hook from
Devin Haney
they're they're fighting they're
claunching and they're hitting oh left
hook from lomachenko and he's pressing
Devin Haney with the jab and he's
staying in Devin Haney section oh left
hand right hand Devin Haney not looking
good jab jab from Aloma machenko and
right hand from lomachenko left hand
from lomachenko Devin Haney is swinging
trying to fight him off him in the
center of the Ring
wants to get his uh his lick back good
jab good jab from Devin Haney
good hack jab from Devin Haney good job
from Devin Haney lomachenko is coming at
him
Fighters quick break and right back to
action oh wait
that was crazy yo these rounds are so
tight and so contentious that you gotta
say uh you got to start picking man I
mean we could be one one V1 I don't I
don't know man
okay
ball Ballers lay this guy out ballot got
here Toe to Toe uh-huh loma's footwork
is magical definitely be definitely
normal gonna get him out of there looks
like they're Loma controlling the fight
Haney's job is nice round thing is Loma
definitely Loma man yeah for real Loma
is crazy I I told dudes you you keep on
thinking that this dude was finished and
he was done man he's not done he's not
cooked
mm-hmm
oh
nice
here we go
here we go these guys are so evenly
matched is crazy
so we got uh
round number four
all right so here we go Devin's uh plan
to get that jab working so now the jab
is working Devin is throwing the jab
he's trying to keep him out he went
straight to loma's body all right so
Loma pushes him comes up on him and
pushes down on his neck
all right here we go so we got uh Loma
goes right back to the double jab and
Devin Haney goes right back to the
double jab right hand to the body he
finishes everything to the body nice
uppercut
and he misses Loma Chango spins around
he catches David Haney with two three
shots and he spins around Devin Haney
Devin Haney's throwing a jab trying to
keep Loma in front of him Loma is being
very cagey
nice job from Loma
Devin Haney is definitely still Liz good
job from Devin Haney Aroma throws the
left hook
any
throws a great job his job is in the
business right now
there we go
oh lomachenko's moving in dark and left
and right
and Devin Haney is throwing the jab to
the top and throw to the bottom
jab to the top
Devin Haney is circling
lomarchenko is shortening distance
and he's pushing him good left hook from
Devin Haney Devin Haney is fighting off
his back foot this is where he's
comfortable at lomachenko is pushing him
now they're both in their well house
right now so you have lomachenko on his
front foot Devin Haney on his back foot
now they're both in their warehouse
right now right hand over the top from
uh from Devin Haney uppercut from Devin
Haney
lomachenko nice job from Devin Haney
lopechenko cutting distance cutting
distance nice uppercut from Devin Haney
nice right hand from lomachenko
right hand from Devin Haney turned in
lomachenko lomachenko's coming in Devin
Haney's controlling distance in his
wheelhouse right now lomachenko throws
three punches and Devin Haney punches
them in the back of the head
good
very good from Devin Haney oh left hook
they both landed good shots both both
landed good shots lomachenko is
dancing
all right so now uh
oh
lomachenko threw Devin Haney to the
floor
this is good
good job from Devin Haney Devin Haney
back to the jab nice right hand
so right now this is the largest round
oh nice right hand nice right to the
body from uh Devin Haney nice jab from
Devin Haney Devin Haney's getting
comfortable he throws a right hand over
the top this round was the biggest round
for Devin Haney that I've seen so far
Devin Haney controlled the distance in
this whole realm Devin Haney was
throwing uppercuts and right hands to
the body Devin Haney was doing exactly
what he needed to do he was in his well
house he was on his back foot and as
lomachenko was coming in he was stopping
with the jab and shoot the right hand
and he'll go under the bottom he'll
bring it over the top he was doing
things to lomachenko that had lomachenko
a little bit frustrated lomachenko then
made sure that he flipped Devin Haney
and put him on his floor
we got 57 watching Haney in the red
that's what's right close round but I
got to give that to Haney that's for
sure streak on your PC stream stream
can't get it for free
loman's on the takedown that's what's up
what's up there we go
ways
beautiful beautiful all right so what
Loma is going to do what what does Loma
have to answer that last round round
number four that I felt that Devin Haney
clearly won
all right here we go Loma stands right
there steadfast in the center of the
Ring he doesn't meet uh uh Haney
all right so uh Haney is standing over
him and Haney is throwing a left hook to
the body left uh right hand to the Head
Devin Haney is throwing a jab
and he's spinning off of Devin uh
lomachenko nice uppercuts to the body
that he's throwing to uh lomachenko I
wonder if that's what Floyd told him to
do that left hook to the body I mean
that right hand to the body lomachenko
is
taking these shots from Devin Haney but
Devin Haney is uh forcing them and now
they're roughing it up in the middle
fights as a professional all right here
we go they're back in the center of the
Ring Devin Haney is giving him shoulder
movement nice jab shoulder movement that
right hand he is not holding that right
hand for uh you know for show he's using
that right hand left hook to the body
he's throwing it he's trying to knock
lomachenko out with that right hand that
right hand keeps coming off his uh off
his guard and he throws it he throws it
with Reckless abandon oh lomachenko
catches Devin Haney twice spins him and
stands behind him
nice right hand oh he's pushing the
Devin Haney is that Devin Haney's body
all right so Devin Haney has to spin him
all right the moment chain goes right
back at it again
oh my God back at it again whip it whip
it all right nice jab uppercut from Loma
machenko all right from Devin Haney
throwing a nice right hand right hand
nice jab from lomachenko they're both at
it again all right so we got uh oh
what happened
he pushed them down I thought he caught
lomachenko with his shot never know
foreign
back to the Jab
love [__] oh that body shot is crazy
he's tearing lomachenko's body up with
that right hand
nice Jab
oh Loma machenko went to the body Devin
Haney came over the top they're out here
fighting for real Devin that jab from
Devon is sickening but Lomo slips it
throws his jab and stands inside
oh nice right hand Devin hand Devin
Haney misses left hand right hand uh LOM
machenko
all right here we go Devin is back at
the Jab
all right
all right he's throwing that right hand
with Reckless abandoned Devin Haney is
nice uppercut from Devin Haney
all right he's stalking lomachenko
all right and Lomo is not trying to
attack at the end of the round like he
normally does
two rounds you gotta give that to Devin
Haney Devin Haney is putting together a
masterful artwork right now she gives me
right hand
is very effective more so effective than
I thought it would ever be it's more
effective than the Jab Devin Haney is
throwing the right hand over the top
under and from the hook side and he's
giving uh lomachenko a lot to think
about now while lomachenko is thinking
about this uppercut coming through Devin
Haney is jabbing him he's keeping his
face at Bay and he's throwing the right
hand over the top and anytime they do
get tied up Devin Haney is still
fighting in the break
oh my God those body shots is crazy
Lumber technical is waiting for the
right moment Devin Haney is that dude
three to one they're really boxing this
is a good fight so far around Devin
Haney 10-9 easy can they keep this pace
up this is what I'm talking about can
they keep this pace up we got 63
watching let's get those like buttons
shout out I'm giving you something
nobody else is going to give you I'm
gonna give you the fight exactly how to
fight is 100 day in the middle of the
Ring right now you have lomachenko
versus Devin Haney Devin Haney and
lomachenko they're both jabbing at each
other Karen Lomo slipped the jab I don't
know if he can but I know right now
Devin Haney is creeping on him and he's
throwing that right to the body he's
keeping lomachenko hands up high because
he knows that right hand is going to be
dropping down to the top
oh left hook from uh Devin Haney nice
right hand to the body from Devin Haney
Devin Haney has no fear of lomachenko's
power at all those body shots is working
Dev uh lomachenko over lomachenko looks
like he's shrinking as each round goes
on he's looking like smaller smaller of
a man he needs to give uh Devin Haney
something to worry about right now
lomachenko is throwing four or five
punches but Devin Haney is undeterred
from what he wants to do
they're standing in the center of the
ring you have a faint from Devin Haney
Devin Haney is pushing the attack and
he's throwing the jab all right right
hand from lomachenko good spin off the
right hand I don't think Devin Haney
knew that was coming but a right hand
from Devin Haney I don't think
lomachenko knew that was coming they're
back right there at it again all right
right to the body right over the top
lomachenko throws a one two three
four five Devin Haney throws two shots
left hook lomachenko throws a one two
Devin Haney is able to take lomachenko's
shots and I don't think that's gonna
change folks we're in round number six
and if lomachenko was going to step it
up and become that veteran that's going
to take over the fight this is the time
that he was supposed to do it and right
now Devin Haney is saying hell no those
belts won't go those belts stay on my
waist lomachenko don't give them and
punches them straight in the face good
right shot
being down
one two from lomachenko on the brink
right now Devin Haney hits him
there goes the jab nice jab from Lane uh
Haney
here we go lomachenko is not being able
to close the distance the ring is too
big for him to establish that distance
lomachenko is backing up Devin Haney is
stalking him throwing us right to the
body those body shots is taking his toll
on malumachenko Devin and Haney is
throwing uppercut's right hands
lemachenko is throwing a right hand and
Devin Haney is working and when he gets
close and Devin Haney is not the one
seeking the clinch folks right now the
clinch is being synced by both Fighters
this is very funny nice nice jab from
Loma from Devin Haney lomachenko
stalking him Devin Haney throws the
uppercut catches on machenko coming in
as Devin Haney backs up Devin Haney is
good on the back foot we have 10 seconds
in a round Devin Haney is still going to
the body he's sticking to his game plan
and he hasn't changed undeterred the man
is definitely on a mission
round six Devin Haney
I'm telling you Devin Haney does not
care Devin Haney is here to win you're
not going to take his belts away
lomachenko you're going to have to turn
into something different you're gonna
have to be greater than you are we have
67 people let's get those likes up in
there I'm gonna give you something more
than you've been getting I'm gonna give
you something that you've been missing
keep watching the fight it's fantastic
let's go body shots
Turd In Style round nine it made me nine
hit that like button that's what's up I
give the edge to Haney right now USA USA
ain't he 4-2 right hook light that's for
fright let's go 72 watching loving a
fight look at that body shot I'm gonna
tell you Devin Haney is in there giving
lomachenko crazy body shot nobody heard
about this nobody thought about this I'm
pretty sure Floyd told him about this
I'm pretty sure that he knew that this
dude don't like body shots and guess
what's happening he's not liking these
body shots
right now lomachenko has slowed down
just a tick if you're looking at it
lomachenko is not darting in and out you
know he's he's dipping his shoulder from
side to side but he's not dipping in and
out no more Devin Haney has got him
pretty much in front of him and he's
pushing him off uh Devin Haney is
showing the superior strength uh his
Superior boxing skills when he comes
into it lomachenko showed Good Foot
speed but again good hand speed
lomachenko lands uh two right hands on
the chin of Devin Haney and Devin Haney
comes right back and lands a left hook
on the side of lomachenko head a right
hand on the side of lomachenko head
they're in the middle of the Ring right
now and Devin Haney goes right to the
body and they're in the clinch the
referee is going to break up the uh the
action right now and they're going to
get right back to it
good jab from Devin Haney double jab
from Devin Haney lomachenko backs up to
the Rope lomachenko spins Devin Haney
lomachenko seems to be frustrated at
this moment folks uh he throws the jab
and he dips over to the right side of uh
Devin Haney he throws a left in the
right hand he's trying to land punches
but the punches aren't Landing right now
he's throwing four shots with those four
shots don't hit Devin Haney seems like
to have oil on his body because he's
moving this guy like it doesn't matter
lomachenko keeps sliding to the side but
Devin Haney is unobturbed right now in
the middle of the Ring good right hand
from Devin Haney left foot I mean right
hand to the body he is tearing
lomachenko up with these right hands
lomachenko throws her uh left hook but
Devin Haney throws this right hand with
such Force right hand to the body
Devin Haney is doing exactly what he
said he was going to do is beat the
brakes off of lomachenko and
lomachenko's trying it hard to figure
out what's going on right hand from
Devin Haney all right Devin Haney is
walking him down now folks Devin Haney
is walking down the former champ left
hand right hand Devin Haney is going to
the body lomachenko's trying to fight
but Devin Haney throws his punches he
stands his ground and he throws his
right hand lomachenko's falling in and
holding
all right so right now
the knights left hook from Devin Haney
lomachenko leans in and he's pressing
Devin Haney Devin Haney's backing up
giving a two-step nice jab to the top
Loma machenko covers up
right hand from Devin Haney
loma's dipping oh that [__] from Devin
Haney oh my God that was crazy he's
going straight to lomachenko's body and
Care lomachenko continue to take these
shots I don't know Devin Haney is going
to the body if he can do this he can
continue to do this this might be a
knockout lomachenko don't care
lomachenko wants to fight this is the
dog that I'm talking about this is the
fight that I was looking for the round
is over but they're gonna come out and
do this again
needs a miracle now I told you Haney has
a respectable power Lomas feeling them
shots yo King
I'm as old 1977 was good body shots go
off in Vegas they ain't cheap those
girls make that money let's share this
joint out on Twitter
trying to tell you guys ain't he might
get rid of this boy Loma got a chin
Haney round seven but close we got 78
watching it all God I love it make sure
you share it out show your friends we
about to do it again round eight boy
loma's in trouble
you know what his father said right
hit it with the bang
teach this dude a lesson Devin Haney
said boy you looking like lunch and I'm
hungry
let's go
right in the center of the Ring We right
back at it again let's go do it
there we go nice Jabs here we go here we
go nice Jabs Loma dipping trying to get
inside he's saying man now I gotta make
a move I gotta make a move on you
all right Devin Haney's not trying to
let him make that move Loma jab isn't
non-existent Devin Haney has his jab on
Deck I'm trying to figure out what
Loomis does
um effectively excuse me besides move
his feet
all right okay so
lomachenko decided to Triple the Jab
and the right hand
all right okay uppercut from lomachenko
all right here we go
Devin Haney's right back to the Jab
all right
oh
those right hands to the body is
something terrible boy
uh-huh oh
lomachenko slipped and fell Sonic
getting tired man signed to getting
tired man
oh man here we go
right hand to the body of lomachenko
from Haney
jab from Loma short right hand over the
top from Haney
oh
all right
left hand from Loma
left hand from Loma he's stalking Devin
Haney I think this is the most pressure
he put on Devin Devin has to withstand
this fight right now in this storm
and if Devin can withstand the storm I
think he can uh
make sure that uh Loma gets this
demoralized in this round
okay good right hand to the body of
Devin Haney
uh-huh
all right Devin Haney threw a left hand
to the body of Loma
all right and he's right back to his jab
right hand from Devin Haney
beautiful beautiful loma's coming in
all right right hand from Devin Haney
good job from Devin Haney
oh good job from Loma catches David
Devin Haney falling back
all right
let's see come on
oh
good left hook
from uh Devin Haney good right hand from
uh I mean good luck Hook from Loma good
right hand from Devin Haney right hand
to the body Aloma
yes
let's go they're in the center of the
Ring Devin Haney's with the right hand
and Loma is uh pushing Devin to the
ropes
right back at it
good jab from Loma good job from Devin
Haney good spin round is over
um
that's a that's a toss-up round uh uh
you're gonna say who did the most work
in that round you got to say Devin Haney
at this point he's just saying a little
bit more active to land in a little bit
more power shots uh he's keeping that
jab inside loma's face and he's doing
the underneath shots but again Loma is
closing distance and he's shooting his
jab I don't know how to referees I mean
how the judges saw that round but uh I
will give it to uh Devin Haney
for anyone who wants to watch clean free
stream uh Han told you long we're gonna
get a slip disc in his back dookie you
crazy dookie ain't slipping with his
predictions on God like Pac-Man with the
punches and bunches can be very
deceptive one of the five punches land
this is true
Loma 10-9 Haney 5-3 watching Manny fight
before the lane suicide is amazing I was
in high school
and I got shocked at his skill
good
here we go
we right back at it
round number nine oh left hook from
Devin Haney on the head of lomachenko
wow these dudes just bugging
they're bugging they're bugging I told
you Devin Haney can't win a fight if
he's walking away from this promoter
this guy gots the knock lomachenko out
man I told you I could see a fight with
Devin Haney wins and lomachenko wins the
belts man I told you
they're back in the center of the Ring
um
Devin Haney is jabbing Lomas jabbing
all right nice right hand and a nice uh
left hand to the face of Devin Haney
from Loma right hand to the body from
Devin Haney
they're right back there nice right hand
over the top from Devin Haney Loma
throws a good jab and he's pressuring
Devin Haney Devon oh left [__] spins
lomachenko check left hook left
that was a crazy uh Devin Haney and
lomachenko is landing shots both in the
center of the Ring one two three by both
oh right hand from Devin Haney these
right hands from Devin Haney is a little
bit different oh la [__] from def uh
lomachenko
this this is what we came to see this is
what we want to see if it's Undisputed
we definitely want to see what they're
going to do for Undisputed and I think
they're going to give you exactly what
oh left hook right hand oh lomachenko is
on Devin Haney he lands four shots on
Devin Haney's head
and Devin Haney's back to his jab
pushing lomachenko back in the center of
the Ring
all right here we go
nice left hook nice right hand from
Devin Haney this is good we got 76
watching let's get those likes popping
let's stop playing here uh-huh nice jab
left hook from uh Devin Haney a moment
that changko's going from side to side
nice right hand from lomachenko
all right Devin Haney back to the Jab
lomachenko Jabs Devin Haney hops back
left hook body shot that body shot was
crazy that body shot is crazy he keeps
digging on machenko body gonna break a
rib on this kid a hun good jab oh left
hook
uh-huh Devin Haney is fighting man oh
that right hand looks good
you know he's throwing a lot of Jabs a
lot of Jabs and right hands
all right we got 14 seconds I mean Devin
Haney is going to lomachenko's body he
is fighting this guy where he wants to
fight him and he's hitting him where he
wants to hit him
good shots man
I Gotta Give Them round number nine to
Devin Haney Devon Haney was showing
those body shots what's crazy close
round honey and he passing them with
that much much more significant body
shots oh that hit was nasty
what was such a moment in time pretty
fight even
he's digging that body oh my God yeah
Haney is wearing Loma out a lesser man
would have been out nah we got 81 people
watching share this out tell somebody
about it it's something different you
seeing something different here it ain't
the same old same I'm gonna tell you how
the fight's going and you're gonna see
it through my eyes I'm gonna give it to
you pause
all right his father is telling him his
father is in his air
here we go
oh
these dudes are not playing if he
catches he he hits
Devin Haney is right back in the center
of the Ring lomachenko's right back in
the center of the Ring
here we go
they're both at it again
think we know we know all right so Devin
Haney understands that he needs to get
these three rounds
good jab from Loma good job from Devin
Haney is uh matadoran uh lomachenko
oh left hook to the body from Devin
Haney
Devin Haney is going to loma's body
oh right hand from uh lomachenko
lomachenko caught Devin Haney with a
couple of shots Devin Haney is holding
on right now
all right so they're back in the center
lomachenko Devin Haney Lake don't look
right I don't know what's going on with
that leg
uh-huh
I don't know what's up with that leg
that leg don't look right
but uh Devin Haney throws a right hand
all right back to the Jab
nice left hook
all right
oh
huh
Devin Haney throwing shots Loma throwing
shots
back to the Jab
Devin Haney
lomachenko is in the section
and he backs up that's kind of crazy
he keeps pulling Devin Haney and he's
he's setting Devin Haney up for a shot
and and lomachenko I mean Devin Haney
catches him with a shot while machenko
pulls in and pulls back faints and pulls
back
faints and pulls back
pain some pulls back
there's more faints going on right now
I'm pulling back
than anything
oh man I yo I really can't stand Timothy
Bradley
is uh
I don't usually use that word for you
know black people so I'm gonna keep it
to myself lomachenko's putting on the
pressure
no more with the the bald bull stands
he's sneaking he's he's commentators on
drugs facts calling only Loma shots you
also got to remember let me tell you
something he's the top right top ranked
fighter right he's still the last dude
there we got 96 watching let's share
that out let's like that let's give that
to somebody else if you don't know now
you know this is exactly what I do this
is what I'm about
lomachenko is the top ranked fighter
right
so the promoter has a vested interest
top rank is calling the fight so top
rank is going to give you their
perspective of said fight all right they
have a horse in the fight lomachenko is
said horse I don't have a horse in the
fight I'm going to give it to you
exactly how you see it lomachenko landed
the most shots that he's ever landed in
that round
I think lomachenko did his best work in
a long time in that round
yeah it's a business don't forget that
so we got round 11 right now if it's
gonna be a knockout if it's gonna be a
knock down let's see what we gonna get
here we go
oh
lombachenko landed a crazy shot oh
oh Devin Haney you better fight there
you better fight boy this is it
lomachenko landed a 1-2 Devin Lane
hanging legs don't look right Devin legs
don't look right devil legs don't look
right Loma jayco's on them
devil legs don't look right lomachenko
is on them
I told you second half of the fight
stuff started looking a little different
oh uppercut right hand Loma Jenkins
Landing no shots oh Devin ain't he about
to go to sleep hey hey hey hey hey hey
Devin Haney trying to swing he trying to
swing low machenkos leaning on them
there we go here we go oh good job
lomachenko right hand jab lomachenko
right hand
left hook right hand
oh oh left hook
right hand Devin Haney trying to fight
them all it's like a harbor shark he's
all on them
lomachango bouncing who said he got that
bold bull stance
working them out Devin Haney trying to
land them shots boy that boy not dead oh
man Loma machenko going to the body
right hand left hook oh my God these
shots is devastating
starting to look sick there baby
starting to look sick there oh right
hand oh
lomachenka looking crazy
looking crazy he bouncing on a whop just
bounce on him that's crazy
he's about he stepped back off of Devin
Haney crazy
right now lomachenko is backing up
he's setting up Devin Haney for some
good stuff some good work
Devin Haney's coming forward
all right
lomachenko's moving from side to side
Devin Haney's going right to
lomachenko's body
all right good job from uh Devin Haney
lomachenko throws a jab
a right hand that round is completely
lomachenko's round
Devin got worried this is fire Hit Me
Baby One More Time King is something
else what up Allison Loma Tim Brown it's
not Fourth of July yeah these shots is
coming pointing on my Hit Me With Your
Best Shot fire away
[Laughter]
what what that boy said what what what
are they using over there
all right this is the last round
this is the last round
we made it what
what
oh snap he hit him with that right hand
I do say who the hell is you
who the hell is you
this is the final countdown
oh lemonade touched the canvas boy push
them
uh-huh ain't he no he has to push it and
he tired man the youngest dude younger
dude tired man
there you go
oh
lomachenko's inside his section boy
keeping it close
keeping it close good job from Damon
all right to the body
to the body
oh
good jab to the body good right hand to
the body
uh huh Timothy Bradley is such a oh boy
a raccoon
he's a Rocket Raccoon
[Laughter]
boy I can't stand that dude I don't like
him I'm sorry guys I do apologize right
hand from Devin Haney right left hook
from Devin Haney right hand to the body
oh oh
good faint
Devin Haney fainted good leaned out
got a minute and a half
all right
all right so right now lomachenko is
going into Devin Haney uh section and
they breaking them up we got one minute
left
one minute left and I really believe
that this fight is hanging on this last
minute whoever wants to get it uh-huh
right hand from Devin Haney
uh-huh love folk from Devin Haney uh-huh
lomachenko's coming into Devin Haney's
body
only back and forth action is Devin
Haney be honest with you Devin Haney has
been carrying this round there's no lie
uh-huh Devin Haney is definitely going
straight to the body
good shots good shots
good shots
uh-huh
body shots is crazy from Loma I mean uh
Devin Haney on loma's body
Devin Haney is definitely here to win
keep his belts
good job
good job uh-huh
[Music]
fights over fights over 12th round and I
can see the robbery in progress
911 we got a robbery in progress we got
a robbery in progress
we got a robbery in progress we can see
it happening
[Laughter]
yo
Mama Said Knock You Out
ain't he ain't gonna win this fight
finish strong let's go Bravo what a
fight
now I don't want none of you guys to be
upset now remember I told everybody if
you follow me on Twitter I got something
special for you after this all you got
to do is look at my Twitter line and
you're gonna see what I'm gonna put up
right before I go to bed I'm gonna put
something up and um on the show tomorrow
it's definitely gonna be something that
we're going to be talking about heavy
no robbery though very close fight
loma's gonna get robbed you said Loma
gonna get robbed
they better not Rob ain't he
never be upset everything can happen
does just flow there it is
there it is
I got a tie you you so so you gotta draw
you gotta draw
I told dudes loma's not done yet
aroma's not done yet
but I'ma tell you this
I would love to see Loma versus tank I
would love to see tank land some of
those shot steady lands because if Devin
can land those shots those body shots to
lomachenko's body I think tank can land
those shots the same shots that
lomachenko body and he can make him do
the the the Ryan Garcia the chill man
don't hit me to the body no more guy
oh let's go
Max got Loma rematch Devon took this no
question
things happen man
things happen
something happened going to the ring
somebody did they thing
boy
did you mess up and pick the wrong guy
I told people
house dude is lomachenko don't think the
house dude was Devin Haney the promoter
owes allegiance to lomachenko because
lomachenko's still going to be with him
Devin Haney will be the odd man out of
this Devin Haney's last fight is on top
rank is this fight he has to renegotiate
if you don't have a belt you're not
renegotiating bruh
let's hold boxing gets it right tonight
let's hope boxing stands on its ones and
twos let's hope boxing is
at its best and shows its best foot
let's let's hope boxing doesn't Rob this
young man
because I think this young man did
enough definitely get a split decision
if not uh a unanimous
you know um
when we're when we're looking at things
right now they're setting stuff up for
the stage and the stage is set and
somebody's gonna walk home with hayachi
face
somebody's gonna get I got circles
oh man
Lomo was definitely more active yeah he
was definitely more active move his feet
more his feet was moving more watch me
call a fight go back and watch the fight
here we go
Dave Moretti scores about
116-12 116 112.
115 113.
whoa
they didn't Rob that boy
boxing got it right tonight
oh
they didn't Rob that boy they didn't Rob
him they didn't Rob him they didn't Rob
him
boxing got it right tonight
boxing got it right
that's right Jason
that's right
that's right boxing got it right tonight
boxing got it right tonight
boxing got it right tonight don't Rob
that boy
boxing got it right tonight
close fight from rayside yo
I want to thank everybody for rocking
out with me
I want you to go to the Twitter
I want you to check my Twitter
Twitter is King David OTW
I want you to go check that out
um
I'm gonna be posting it
right now before I go to bed
it's
it was amazing time with you guys
tonight I want to thank everybody for
showing up
I truly appreciate each and every last
one of you thank you so much and um I
want you guys to watch this outro
uh I'm gonna give y'all the outro this
was fantastic it was amazing
we did it again
I'ma give y'all an outro right now
[Music]
uh
might lose
[Music]
it if you really want it in the ring I
don't send the contract off knock his
contacts out you will feel mice trying
to take a Viper ain't no competition in
the ring of Cypher cause I'm spitting
phenomenal swinging fire talking pickled
peppers make them pay to Piper cause I
might go live like rude discussion and
deflate your chest like a food reduction
you'll be talking like you want a new
concussion Center dude a custom attitude
adjustment these are fighting words
better give me that respect that I
deserve for another sandwich
even got his winning only homie Kevin
you a phony homie now you owe me action
have em thinking Tony Toni Toni Braxton
and they all want to talk for attention
but the fame only lasts for an instant
mama got handsome and bread for the
tension imma leave them red you can
dance in Redemption
laughs
[Music]